Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 240 mit dem schönen Titel Fünf Jahre Wikidata. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich spreche Mikrofone und werde versuchen, durch den heutigen Abend zu führen, der live in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin stattfindet, das heißt dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin und das kann man auch hören. Wie ihr hört, es sind Leute da, aber es ist auch noch ein bisschen Platz. Ihr könnt gerne vorbeikommen, wenn ihr wollt und das gerade live hört. Wenn ihr den Podcast hört, würde ich das nur unter Umständen empfehlen. Wenn es gerade Donnerstag Abend ist, dann ja. Ansonsten eher nicht. Wir reden heute über Wikidata und mit der kurzen Aufmerksamkeitsspanne der Menschen, würde ich sagen, alle denken jetzt, ja, Wikidata kenn ich, das ist diese große Internetplattform, wo ich meine Hausarbeiten immer abgeschrieben habe. Fast, fast. Ich heiße herzlich willkommen von Wikidata, Lydia Pitcher. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Was genau bist du und was machst du und warum bist du heute hier?
Ich bin die Produktmanagerin für Wikidata und bin hier um mit dir und meinen Kollegen über Wikidata zu quatschen.
Okay, die Kollegen, das sind Jens Ohlig. Hallo, Roland, da.
Hallo.
Warum bist du hier? Wer bist du? Was machst du?
Ich arbeite beruflich damit mit Wikidata bzw. ja, schon seit fünf Jahren von Anfang an und finde das immer noch toll, wie am ersten Tag.
Okay und Lukas Werkmeister war auch noch da. Hallo, Roland, Abend.
Hallo.
Du bist wer, was, warum?
Ursprünglich als Freiwilliger zugestoßen. Mittlerweile arbeite ich auch bei Wikimedia Deutschland mit. Alles bekannt im Moment und bin hier, um auch zu quatschen über Wikidata, besonders die lustigen Sachen, die man damit machen kann, ein paar Anekdoten, witzige Daten, die man rausholen kann.
Okay, das werden wir uns gleich genau erklären lassen. Der Untertitel der heutigen Sendung ist das Wissen der Welt instrukturiert und maschinenlesbar und wie gesagt ist ja Wikidata nicht die Wikipedia, aber hat schon was damit zu tun und ich hätte jetzt also im Grunde genommen als ich zum ersten Mal von dem Thema gehört habe gesagt, also das Wissen der Welt, instrukturierte Maschinenlesbar, das ist doch in der Wikipedia. Ich meine also das ist ja da, das ist ein Wiki, da kann man irgendwie in so einer Art Struktur sich auch durchsuchen lassen. Die Artikel sind schön verschlagwortet. Man weiß also, dass wenn man da irgendwas zu einem Typen liest, meistens ob das ein Mann oder eine Frau ist, die Berufsbezeichnung, ob er aus einem bestimmten Land herkommt. Jetzt gibt es aber noch ein extra Projekt, also Wikipedia, über das wir heute reden werden. Aber bevor wir das machen, vielleicht doch die Frage, was fehlt denn in der Wikipedia noch?
Was fehlt denn in der Wikipedia noch Lydia? Also ist schon ziemlich viel drin und man kann da auch einiges rauslesen. Wenn man halt ganz einfache Fragen stellt, wie zum Beispiel die Frage, die wir uns auch bei der Entwicklung am Anfang gestellt haben, gib mir eine Liste aus von den zehn größten Städten der Welt, wo eine Frau als Bürgermeisterin ist. Dann findet man diese Information auf jeden Fall in der Wikipedia, aber viel Spaß beim rausfinden. Man müsste nachher erst alle Städte durchgucken, wer hat da das Bürgermeisteramt, welches Geschlecht hat die Person, wie viele Einwohner hat die Stadt und das dann auch nach Einwohnerzahl sortieren. Das wäre ziemlich anstrengend.
Aber warum? Die Wikipedia funktioniert ja über das Media-Wiki. Und schon wenn man das schreibt, werden ja in den Texten die Begriffe mit Tags eingeschlossen. Das Ganze wird ja auch als Code repräsentiert. Warum kann man das nicht eh schon?
Es gab in der Tat auch schon mal früh Versuche. In ein paar Wochen beginnt der Chaos Communication Congress. Da kommt ja auch eine Software zum Einsatz, die auf das Media-Wiki aufsetzt. Das ist das Semantic Media Wiki, wo man dann noch mal Zusatzinformationen, Metadaten in das Wiki reinpacken kann. Das ist im Grunde eine Parallelentwicklung oder der Anfang von der Idee, aus der dann Wikidata geworden ist. Du hast das damals in Karlsruhe auch live mitgekriegt, was dahintersteckt.
Also es gab die Idee, Semantik in Wikipedia zu bringen, um genau die…
Ich muss an dieser Stelle nachfragen. Ich weiß, dass es schwierig zu erklären ist, aber ich scheitere daran selber auch häufiger als mein Liebes, was genau ist Semantik und welche Rolle spielt in der Wikipedia?
In dem Fall würde das heißen, dass man den Text in der Wikipedia mit zusätzlicher Bedeutung hinterlegt. Also zum Beispiel, dass in einem Satz, Berlin ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland, eben auch für einen Computer verständlich ist, was diese Beziehung eigentlich bedeutet und was die einzelnen Konzepte darin bedeuten. Also Berlin, Deutschland, was eine Hauptstadt ist, diese Dinge. Denn als Mensch kann ich verstehen, was das bedeutet. Für eine Maschine ist das wesentlich schwerer.
Moment mal, aber wir hören noch irgendwie, also jeden Tag jetzt mittlerweile, dass die künstliche Intelligenz bald unseren Planeten übernehmen wird und uns endlich relevante Werbung auf Webseiten anzeigt. Aber das geht noch nicht von alleine?
Das geht schon erschreckend gut. Und das wird auch sicherlich immer besser werden. Die Frage ist nur, wollen wir uns darauf verlassen, dass irgendwelche Maschinen aus, für Menschen, von Menschen geschriebenen Aufsätzen Bedeutungen rausprokeln? Oder schreiben wir die Bedeutungen einfach explizit dahin und helfen den Maschinen ein bisschen beim Schlauer werden?
Okay, mich würde interessieren, wie der Anfang der ganzen Geschichte ist. Weil in meinem Kopf ist es immer so, hätte ich gedacht, das ist eigentlich die Geschichte der Wikipedia. Leute setzen sich zusammen und sagen, lass uns mal dieses ganze Wissensding online machen. Das hat zwei Vorteile. Der erste ist, jeder kann mitmachen. Der andere ist, wir haben das sofort maschinenlesbar da.
Ich glaube, am Anfang ging es eher um das, jeder kann mitmachen. Und das ist dann sofort maschinenlesbar da. Das hat man dann versucht, über irgendwelche Hacks zu lösen. Die Idee ist aber nicht wirklich neu, das Web auch maschinenlesbar zu machen. Eigentlich war die von Anfang an da. Und der Vater vom World Wide Web, Bernas Lee, hat auch gleich, nachdem er irgendwie mit HTML gesagt hat, wir machen Dokumente, die man verlinken kann, hat er dann auch gleich gesagt, wir brauchen auch Dokumente, die maschinenlesbar sind und wo dann die Browser Beziehungen zwischen Seiten feststellen können. Das ist dieser Traum vor dem semantischen Web, der bis heute nicht eingelöst worden ist.
Warum? Woran ist der gescheitert? Das ist schon wieder die Frage, was fehlte. Es ist anscheinend nicht nur in der Wikipedia, wo es eh total nahe liegt, sondern es war von Anfang an der Plan, erfahre ich gerade. Aber es ist trotzdem 2017 und wir haben es noch nicht. Warum? Ist das sozusagen sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Datenschutz oder User-Interface-Design, wo man sagt, ja, wäre eine geile Idee, machen wir später?
Es ist ganz schwierig, das auf eine Art und Weise hinzubekommen, die nutzerfreundlich ist und die in der Masse an Menschen zugänglich ist.
Aber muss das zugänglich inwiefern? Ich dachte eher, das ist eine Technologie, die hinter den Kulissen stattfindet.
Ja, genau. Aber letztendlich müssen dann doch Menschen Kategorien schaffen oder Kategorien befüllen und so. Und wenn es nur Menschen sind, die Codes schreiben, der Kategorien befüllt. Wenn ich versuche, die Ordnung der Dinge herzustellen und sage, ich mach mal eine Ordnung für alle möglichen Dinge im Universum, da kann ich mich dann entweder mal drei Jahrzehnte in den universitären Elfenbeinturm vergraben und sagen, am Schluss habe ich dann die ultimative Ordnung aller Dinge im Universum und alle Unterklassen von Sternenstaub und so. Oder ich kann sagen, wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an. Diese semantische Web ist glaube ich eher davon aufgehalten worden, dass die Leute eher die erste Option mit wir sperren uns jetzt mal in den Elfenbeinturm ein und finden dann die die Ordnung für alles. Und dieses wir fangen einfach mal an ist mehr so dieser Wiki Ansatz tatsächlich.
Also das heißt eigentlich hat das Ding zwei Probleme. Der erste ist, wenn man also nicht nur wenn man nicht nur will, dass die Leute das in die Wikipedia reinschreiben, sondern auch noch so aufarbeiten, dass das gleich in diesen Strukturen reinpasst, dann müssen die noch mehr arbeiten freiwillig. Und das andere ist, damit wir das machen können, müssen sich Menschen auf Strukturen einigen. Und das ist dann wieder schon sozusagen sehr langweilig, weil sich Menschen auf Strukturen einigen. Wie hat das jetzt mit Wikidata angefangen? Also der Titel der Sendung ist ja Fünf Jahre. Man kann auch sagen, also wir haben fünf Jahre Zeit gehabt. Warum ist das immer noch nicht da? Wie hat es angefangen und was ist passiert seitdem?
Es ist noch viel schlimmer, es hat ja noch viel früher angefangen.
Auf der allerersten Wikimania, Wikimania ist die Konferenz der Wikipedia und verwandten Projekte. 2005. Da haben zwei Wissenschaftler gesagt, lass uns das jetzt mal angehen, lass uns mal die Wikipedia semantisch machen. Und waren da sehr enthusiastisch. Haben ein Paper dazugeschrieben, haben es vorgestellt, ihre Idee und so. Und es fanden alle eigentlich relativ cool. Aber so richtig vorwärts ging es nicht.
Und das ist erstaunlich, denn der eine Autor von dem Paper hat gesagt, das ist keine schwierige Aufgabe. Also jemand, der sich mit Programmieren auskrennt, kann das sicherlich in drei Monaten programmieren.
Aber da haben doch alle gelacht, oder? Ich habe dir gerade erklärt, wie schwer semantisches Netz zu schaffen ist.
Er hat sich leicht verschätzt.
Und dann war das so, alle so geile Ideen. Das wird schon irgendjemand machen, Verantwortungstiffusion quasi, oder? Was passiert?
Wahrscheinlich, genau. Aber dann haben die beiden sich zusammengesetzt und angefangen, ein Semantik-Media-Wiki zu programmieren.
Was ist ein Semantik-Media-Wiki?
Na, jeder, der schon mal auf dem Chaos-Kongress war, kennt das. Also wir haben da diese Wiki-Seite vom CTC-Kongress. Und wenn man dann sehen möchte, wo der nächste Geldautomat ist, dann kann man das einfach auf einer speziellen Seite sehen, weil die Geldautomaten werden dann nochmal ausgezeichnet und die Adressen werden nochmal ausgezeichnet. Und weil die halt nochmal als Maschinenleser, der Text, der jetzt kommt, ist eine Straßenadresse reingeschrieben werden ins Wiki, kann dann gleich die Open-Street-Map generiert werden und so weiter. Also man schreibt nicht nur einfach Text für die menschliche Verarbeitung in das Wiki rein, sondern macht noch ein bisschen extra Arbeit und sagt, hallo, hier ist eine Straßenadresse und dann kann daraus eine Open-Street-Map generiert werden. Das ist Semantik Media Wiki und das geht schon sehr nahe in die Richtung. Die Daten werden dann jetzt nicht nur für Menschen lesbar, sondern auch für Maschinen.
Und dann kann man darüber eben zum Beispiel Abfragen machen und dann kannst du dir eine Karte anzeigen lassen mit den Geldautomaten oder mit den Geldautomaten und Hotels und Veranstaltungsorten gleichzeitig, je nachdem was du brauchst. Das haben die beiden also programmiert, mit der Hilfe von natürlich einer Community, mit dem Ursprungsgedanken, dass das das ist, was Wikipedia semantisch macht. Aus mehreren Gründen hat das aber nie seinen Weg in Wikipedia selbst gefunden, sondern es wird benutzt in internen Firmenetzwerken als Wiki, es wird für den Congress benutzt und so weiter. Es ist ein relativ erfolgreiches Projekt, aber nicht auf Wikipedia.
Nicht da, wo es eigentlich hin soll?
Genau.
Warum? Ich kann es nicht genau formulieren, warum?
Das eine ist Performance. Es ist nicht gebaut, um auf der Größe von Wikipedia laufen zu können. Aber der viel fundamentalere Gedanke ist, dass Wikipedia sehr auf Referenzen ist. Also Daten in Wikipedia, Hauptungen in Wikipedia sollten eine Referenz haben. Das war eine der Dinge, die die beiden von Semantik Media Wiki gelernt haben, dass es das braucht und dann in Wikidata übernommen haben. Die andere Sache, die ist nicht so...
Stopp, ich versteh das Problem nicht. Also der Maul, der man in Semantik Media Wiki, was, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, einfach bedeutet, ich trage auch da Dinge ein, aber ich mache mir mehr Arbeit und beschreibe durch Codewörter im wechselnden Eintrag, was das bedeutet, also gebe ich mir die Beziehung vor. In dem normalen Media Wiki gibt es so viele Referenzen. Warum ist das ein Problem? Also warum führt das dazu, dass die beiden nicht zusammenkommen?
Es ist einfach nicht wirklich benutzerfreundlich, Daten so zu referenzieren in Semantik Media Wiki, wie es eigentlich sein müsste, fragen wir es so.
Dass ich dann zu einer Körpergröße von einer Person auch die Quellenangabe da reinschreibe und so. Das hatten sie nicht drin. Das andere Problem ist, glaube ich, dass die Realität im Zweifelsfall und die Realität, mit der Wikipedia zu tun hat, immer ein Stückchen dreckiger ist, als man sich das an seinen schlimmsten Träumen vorstellt. Wir haben ganz viele Sachen, wo wir auch widersprüchliche Aussagen haben, die beide mit Quellen belegbar sind. Wenn man sich auf Wikidata anguckt, da gibt es die Halbinsel Grimm und dann gibt es die Beziehung gehört zu dem und dem Staat. Da gibt es zwei Aussagen, die nebeneinander stehen. Zu welchem Staat das gehört, die beide mit Quellen belegbar sind. Aber warum ist das ein Problem? In einer Datenbank, mit der man sonst arbeitet, wo es halt so einen Key Value Store gibt, also zu jedem Schlüssel gibt es einen Wert, funktioniert das einfach nicht, dass einfach mal widersprüchliche Sachen nebeneinander stehen können.
Das System ist so, dass man immer nur einen Wert setzen kann?
Nicht unbedingt so, aber ja, das ist zum Beispiel etwas, also wir wollten, es soll halt selbst diese Modellierung der Daten, soll halt Wikistyle im Fluss sein. Als wir angefangen haben, gab es natürlich irgendwie diese Beziehung, diese Bezeichnung für Sex oder Gender. Und da gab es dann halt zwei Werte, die da möglich sind. Ich glaube im Moment werden 17 oder so benutzt von der Community, weil man es dann einfach nochmal differenzierter haben möchte.
Und dann war es schwierig, das System so zu bauen, dass es möglich ist, dass es sich noch ändert.
Also bei Wikidata ist das halt Teil des Systems, dass auch die Ordnung der Dinge sich jederzeit ändern kann. Dass auch die Ordnung der Dinge halt Wikistyle ummodelliert werden kann. Weil so ist einfach das Wissen in der Welt angelegt. Du denkst halt vielleicht, okay, so eine Beziehung wie ist verheiratet mit, das kann nur zwischen zwei Menschen sein.
Ja, ich habe also genug Dinge gesehen, um das anzuzweifeln.
Genau, und dann findet man heraus, es gibt irgendwie eine Frau, die ist mit dem Eiffelturm verheiratet und merkt dann, okay, so eine Festlegung auf bestimmte Objekte darf man dann einfach nicht machen. Dafür ist unsere Realität nicht ausgelegt. Oder man geht davon aus, dass ein Datum auf eine bestimmte Art aufgebaut ist. Und dann findet man heraus, in Finnland gab es bei der Umstellung vom Julianischen auf dem Gregorianischen Kalender auch mal den 31. Februar. Sowas muss man halt auch eintreiben können.
Und dann hinkt man sozusagen mit dem Semantik-Media-Wiki immer hinterher? Und deswegen ist das noch nicht im richtigen Media-Wiki drin?
Es war einfach vom Design her nie so aufgebaut, um mit diesen Widersprüchen gut umgehen zu können. Das ist eine weitere Lesson learned sozusagen, die die beiden mitgenommen haben, um Wikidata dann zu konzipieren.
Bei Semantik-Media-Wiki zeichnest du Sachen in einer Wikiseite halt aus. Bei Wikidata dreht sich alles um Wissensgegenstände, die dann mit Aussagen beschrieben werden.
Ich glaube, in der Tat, es ist zu kompliziert für den normalen User oder der Userin, das kann ich schon jetzt nachvollziehen, weil ich denke, ich kann mir überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen, wie das läuft. Ich will mal noch zu dem anderen Punkt, den ich am Anfang gesagt habe, zurückkommen, nämlich dass er meinte, das wäre zu anspruchsvoll oder nicht performant genug, um auf dem normalen Wikipediasystem zu laufen. Da frage ich mich aber, was genau generiert da so eine große Last? Weil letztlich, wie es erklärt hat, ist das für einen Menschen sehr umständlich, das ganze Zeug da so einzutragen, die Beziehungen herzustellen und die Quellen zu sagen und so weiter und so fort. Aber das ist ja letztlich nur mehr Text. Warum ist das kompliziert für die Maschine? Die Wikipedia ist jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Computer, der irgendwo ins Internet angeschlossen ist. Da steht schon ein bisschen Rechenpower hinter, würde ich denken.
Das ist korrekt. Aber bei Semantik Media Wiki geht es ja nicht nur darum, dass man Teile von dem Textmaschinenlesbar auszeichnet, sondern der Clou ist ja dann, dass man darüber Abfragen machen kann. Und die Abfragen in dem Fall würden über mehrere Millionen Wikiseiten gehen.
Das ist cool.
Das ist total cool. Aber leider in der Art, wie das gebaut war, nicht performant.
Also das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ein Mensch eine Anfrage macht, wo möglicherweise einmal alle Wikiseiten gelesen werden müssen, dann bringt das das System in die Knie. Ist das Problem überhaupt klärbar? Also vielleicht. Wir sind ziemlich sicher, dass...
Zumindest arbeiten wir daran.
Was ich jetzt auch noch interessant finde, diese eine Frage noch vor die erste halbe Stunde schon wieder rum ist, ist, einerseits seid ihr alles drei Leute, die bei Wikidata arbeiten. Andererseits sagt ihr immer, die beiden. Erstens, wie sind die Namen?
Danny Vranicic und Markus Skoc.
Und sozusagen wieso seid ihr Wikidata-Leute? Aber sprecht immer nur davon, dass die beiden das machen.
Okay. Markus Skoc kommt aus der akademischen Welt, ist auch Professor geblieben. Dann, Danny hat dann auch tatsächlich bei Wikimedia Deutschland angefangen zu arbeiten und war dann derjenige, der für das Projekt verantwortlich war. Und dann fing es an, bei Wikimedia Deutschland gab es sozusagen ein Hacker-Casting und dann wurden halt Leute eingestellt, die dann daran arbeiten können vor fünf Jahren. Mittlerweile hat Danny gesagt, okay, das läuft. Und ist jetzt Ontologe, also beschäftigt sich mit der Ordnung der Dinge bei einer Suchmaschinenfirma mit G.
Okay, das heißt also, die haben die beiden, die beiden, die heilige Zweifaltigkeit des Wikidats, die haben sozusagen die theoretische Grundlagenarbeit, das Fundament sozusagen gelegt und jetzt baut ihr da drauf.
Genau, und wir arbeiten da seit fünf Jahren an der Software. Lydia treibt uns an und wir versuchen das umzusetzen.
Gibt es auch sowas wie semantische Peitschen? Das klären wir später. Jetzt machen wir erst eine kleine Unterbrechung und reden gleich darüber, was man jetzt genau mit Wikidata schon machen kann. Vorher gibt es aber, wie es sich für ein ordentliches Chaosradio gehört, die Nerd-News und die sind geschrieben von Mo und werden präsentiert von Helena.
Marcus Hutchins vorläufig auf freiem Fuß. Der auf Twitter unter dem Namen Malware Techblock bekannte Hacker wurde im August vom FBI in Las Vegas verhaftet. Ihm wurde vorgeworfen, den Banking Trojaner Kronos entwickelt zu haben. Weil die Behörden seine Flucht ins Ausland befürchteten, stellten sie ihn unter Hausarrest und überwachten seinen Standort per GPS. Nach einem Bericht von Spiegel Online soll sich Marcus Hutchins wieder frei bewegen dürfen. Hutchins hatte in der Vergangenheit weltweiten Ruhm erlangt, weil er die Ausbreitung des Verschlüsselungstrojaners WannaCry verzögert hatte. Krak-Attacke Durch Fehler im WPA2-Protokoll können verschlüsselte Daten zwischen einem Access Point und einem Client eingesehen werden. WPA2 ist das meistgenutzte Protokoll für die Verschlüsselung in Funknetzen. Es soll verhindern, dass Daten aus der Funkübertragung erschnüffelt werden. Durch den Krak-Angriff, der sich in den Verbindungsaufbau einklingt, können Angreifer diese Informationen mitschneiden oder Daten manipulieren. Landgericht Hamburg distanziert sich von eigener Rechtsprechung. Das Hamburger Landgericht hält nicht mehr an seinem strengen Haftungsmaßstab bei Verlinkungen auf Urheberrechtsverletzende Inhalte fest. Im September 2016 entschied der Europäische Gerichtshof, dass der Betreiber einer Webseite für das Setzen eines Links auf urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke haften kann, wenn der Link mit der Absicht gesetzt wurde, Gewinn zu erzielen. Vom Linksetzenden wird erwartet, dass er nachprüft, dass das betroffene Werk nicht unbefugt veröffentlicht wurde. Wie dies in der Praxis umgesetzt werden soll, liest der EUGH offen. Kurz danach bestätigte das Landgericht Hamburg die Linie in einem Beschluss. Wie jetzt bekannt wurde, änderte das Landgericht in einem weiteren Beschluss ein halbes Jahr später seine Auffassung. Eine Nachprüfung sei bei gewerblicher Linksetzung in der Regel nicht zu. Nicht zumutbar.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die juristische Medienwelt in Deutschland nur halb so spannend wäre. Hätten wir das Landgericht Hamburg nicht? Wenn ihr genau lachen wollt, da Chaosradio ccc.de gibt es in den Show notes die Links zu unseren Nerd News. Chiptunes for the win ist der Name einer Sampler oder Compilation Reihe, die im August dieses Jahres, wie ich es jetzt erfahren habe, mit dem sechsten Teil rausgekommen sind und von dieser Compilation war das Knasi Bass mit Rural. Wir hören noch ein bisschen mehr Musik hier im Chaos Radio 240, wo es aber um Wikidata geht. Ein Unternehmen, das helfen soll, dass man die Dinge, die in der Wikipedia stehen, auch in Maschinen lesbar darstellen und noch viel wichtiger Beziehungen herstellen und abfragen kann. Habe ich die erste halbe Stunde dieser Sendung richtig verstanden? Lydia, Jens und Lukas.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Da war schon viel schönes dabei.
Bin ich jetzt Semantiker? Fast. Fast, okay. Ihr habt ja erklärt, die Idee gibt es seit 2005, konkret gearbeitet an einem Projekt, also an der Realisation sozusagen wird es seit fünf Jahren. Ist es gemein, wenn ich jetzt frage, was kann das schon?
Nee, das ist völlig korrekt. Für Spendengelder soll man auch was sehen können.
Das ist ja auch interessant. Jetzt, wo du das gesagt hast, müssen wir mal einen Schlenker machen. Also ihr seid ja, ihr seid beim Projekt Wikidata. Ihr arbeitet für die Wikimedia, was ja der Verein ist, der nicht die Wikipedia ist, aber sich um die Belange der Wikipedia kümmert. Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen. Jetzt, und da muss ja, also das ist ja auch sozusagen, du bist ja Projekt Lydia, du bist ja Projektmanagerin. Produktmanagerin, Entschuldigung. Das heißt sozusagen, das hat ja auch so einen institutionellen Charakter. Jens, du hast gerade gesagt, man ist natürlich auch irgendwie so Rechenschaft schuldig, mit dem Spendengelder passiert. Wie ist denn das, also wie war denn der Entscheidungspreis zu sagen, okay, wir geben jetzt dafür Geld aus? Musste man da Überzeugungsarbeit leisten? Oder war sofort allen klar, wenn wir dieses verdammte Weltwissen haben, müssen wir das natürlich auch in einer Weise aufarbeiten, die Maschinenlesbar ist?
Nee, das war leider nicht allen klar. Also da muss es schon eine ganze Menge Überzeugungsarbeit geleistet werden und um Spenden gebeten werden.
Also nochmal extra sozusagen?
Genau. In dem Fall haben wir die Finanzierung für den Projekt Start von Google, AI Squared und der Golden Embedded More Foundation bekommen, die sozusagen das erste Jahr Entwicklung finanziert haben und danach kommt die Finanzierung aus den üblichen Spendengeldern, die Wikimedia einnimmt.
Aber das heißt, wir haben dieses liebenswerte Banner, was wir einmal im Jahr über der Wikipedia sehen. Das Ergebnis davon ist ja ein großer Topf Geld und da kriegt ihr wiederum auch Dinge draus. Und müsst ihr da jetzt jedes Jahr irgendwie von neuem darum bitten, dass da irgendwie Geld rumkommt? Oder ist das jetzt so, okay, das Projekt wird bis zu mir dadurch finanziert?
Natürlich muss jedes Projekt innerhalb von Wikimedia seine Existenz rechtfertigen, sag ich mal.
Aber ich will die Frage präzise stellen, es gibt den Unterschied zwischen so, okay, liebe Leute, letztes Jahr haben wir das erreicht, dieses Jahr wollen wir das erreichen und wir sind noch so weit entfernt vom Ziel. Das ist ja was anderes, als jedes Jahr zu sagen müssen, hey, es ist wirklich wichtig, dass es das gibt. Wir müssen das Projekt weitermachen, weil es ein wesentlicher Bestandteil dieser ganzen Nummer ist.
Genau, nee, darüber sind wir zum Glück hinaus und die Leute erkennen, dass es ein ganz zentrales, ein ganz zentraler Bestandteil von Wikipedias Zukunft ist.
So, dann kommen wir jetzt zu der Frage, was kann das denn schon? An welcher Stelle seid ihr? Kann man das schon benutzen?
Das kann man auf jeden Fall schon benutzen. Einerseits haben wir eine große Community, die sich auf wikidata.org um strukturierte Daten kümmert. Die Daten sammelt, kuratiert, freigibt für die Benutzung. In Wikipedia, aber auch außerhalb.
Ich wollte mal sagen, wird das dann so gemacht, es gibt für Wikidata eine Wikipedia-Kopie, mit der dann gearbeitet wird, oder wie rum funktioniert das?
Nein, also auch wikidata.org läuft eine Media-Wiki-Instanz mit speziellen Actensions, die dafür sorgen, dass man da strukturierte Daten pflegen kann. Also, dass man dann zum Beispiel eine Seite für Berlin hat, auf der man so Sachen angeben kann, wie wer ist der Bürgermeister, wie viele Einwohner leben in Berlin und so weiter.
Das hat nichts mit der Wikipedia zu tun, das wurde eigentlich alles noch mal von vorne gemacht, oder?
Da sind auch ein paar Sachen aus der Wikipedia übernommen worden, aber das soll dann halt auch vielleicht irgendwann mal ersetzt werden durch andere Quellen. Es gibt mehrere, also Wikidata soll mehrere Zwecke erfüllen. Ansberg ist immer gewesen, wir wollen die Wikipedia unterstützen, dass die dann zum Beispiel ihre Infoboxen aus Wikidata beziehen können, aber es soll auch immer ein Projekt sein, was für sich stehen kann und wo Leute von außerhalb dann spannende Anwendungen schreiben können.
Halt, bis jetzt war ich davon ausgegangen, dass Endgame in der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass innerhalb der Wikipedia alles, was da drin steht, auch diese semantischen Informationen enthält. Jetzt klingt es gerade so, ihr baut eine Technologie, die wird an einer Stelle in einem Wikipedia-Artikel vielleicht eine Rolle spielen, aber nicht sozusagen in dem ganzen Ding.
Ist nicht so widersprüchlich. Vielleicht meinen wir auch das Gleiche. Was wir auf jeden Fall nicht machen, ist, dass wir einfach die Wikipedia semantifizieren. Das machen wir auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber es kann an verschiedenen Stellen in der Wikipedia eingesetzt werden. Da die unterschiedlichen Wikipedia-Communities unterschiedlich innovationsfreudig sind, kann das dann auch in einer kleineren Wikipedia, wo es nur wenige Leute gibt, schneller eingesetzt werden. Und die größeren Wikipedia, die deutsche, die englischsprachige Wikipedia, die sagen, wir setzen auf Hand und Wertarbeit, die setzen vielleicht im Moment Wikidata noch ein bisschen sporadischer ein. Aber das wird sich alles in den nächsten Jahren verändern.
Ist das denn eigentlich Wikidata sozusagen so eine Technologie oder eine Art und Weise zu coden, die die sprachübergreifend funktioniert? Oder muss es dann noch mal extra Versionen geben für? Also ich versuche jetzt so einen Vergleich zu ziehen. Also bei der Programmiersprache irgendwie muss die Erklärung natürlich in der Sprache geschrieben sein, die ich auch verstehe. Aber die Programmi, also die Funktionsnamen in der Programmiersprache sind ja sozusagen international überall gleich.
Na gar nicht, man, die sind meistens auf Englisch, weil...
Na ja klar, wir sind für alle in Englisch.
Aber wir haben es gedacht, also Englisch ist halt auch... Also wir gehen nicht davon aus, dass die 300 Sprachen, wo es Wikipedia drin gibt, dass das alle Sonderfälle vom Englischen sind. Sondern wir gehen davon aus, dass es im Grunde erst mal gar keine Sprache gibt, sondern nur Zahlen. Genau, und diese Zahlen kann ich dann halt in meiner Lieblingssprache mit dem Bezeichner dann darstellen lassen. Also, machen wir ein konkretes Beispiel. Ich wollte gerade fragen, danke. Es gibt ein Wissensgegenstand zu der Stadt, in der wir uns gerade hier befinden. Das ist Berlin. Und auf Wikidata heißt dieser Wissensgegenstand Q64. Das ist die Nummer für Berlin. Die fangen alle mit Q an und dann kommt eine Nummer. Und da Berlin ziemlich früh angelegt wurde in Wikidata, hat es eine sehr kleine Nummer, eine 2-stellige. Und Q64, wenn ich mein Interface jetzt auf Deutsch eingestellt habe, kommt der Berlin raus. Wenn ich es auf Englisch eingestellt habe, kommen die gleichen Schriftzeichen raus. Berlin. Aber wenn ich es auf Koreanisch einstelle, steht da Bangnim. Und sieht auch schon ein bisschen anders aus, weil da andere Schriftzeichen rauskommen. Es ist aber alles Q64.
Aber auch das Koreanisch, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist auch sozusagen deren Wort für diese Stadt.
Genau. Und wenn ich dann auch so Sachen mache, wie ist Hauptstadt von, das heißt dann im deutschen Interface Hauptstadt von und auf Englisch ist Capital of. Und das sind aber dann wieder nur Zahlen, die dann halt übersetzt werden. Wenn ich also jetzt eine kleine Sprache habe, eine kleine Wikipedia, und das ist sehr hilfreich, die fangen dann an und wollen auch irgendwelche Artikel, Infoboxen, Grunddaten über irgendwie zum Beispiel ein Land oder eine Stadt haben.
Weil ich nur kurz so ein bisschen verstehen kann. Also die Information, Berlin ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland, ist dann im Prinzip eine Zahlenfolge Q64, Q38, Q189 oder wie?
Im Prinzip schon. Also diese Prädikate fangen dann mit P anstatt mit Q an. Aber ja, genauso wie es ist. Und das wird dann halt, wenn ich das Interface umstelle, übersetzt in die jeweilige Sprache, in der ich es angezeigt habe.
Das muss dann auch wieder jemand machen?
Das muss jemand machen, aber das ist relativ wenig Arbeit, weil meistens Leute dann halt aus dem Englischen oder so aus einer anderen großen Sprache das dann schnell in ihre kleine Sprache übersetzt haben. Und sobald sie einmal das übersetzt haben, ist Hauptstadt von, haben sie das für alle anderen ähnlichen Wissensgegenstände ja auch gleich mitgeliefert.
Aber das machen wir in Wikipedia ja ja auch.
Naja, aber das ist der Punkt, wo ich mir das einfacher vorstelle. Also ich persönlich habe, also ich bin total schlechter und progressionierender Schreiber, aber ich tendenziell kann ich es mir vorstellen, einen Artikel über eine Hauptstadt zu schreiben, aber mir dann noch die Arbeit zu machen, diese ganzen Dinge irgendwie da reinzubasteln, I don't know.
Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen Größenwahn so, also überhaupt, ja, wenn man halt sagt irgendwie, ja, wir machen jetzt einfach mal das Wissen der gesamten Menschheit in Maschinen ist bei uns, ist schon klar, dass wir da jetzt nächste Woche Mittwoch mit fertig sind.
Wie ist das eigentlich, wird das gezielt vorangetrieben, dass die Dinge sozusagen aufgebaut werden? Also man könnte jetzt sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt, also hier deutsche Wikidata, fangen wir also an mit Städten, dann machen wir erstmal die großen Städte, sorgen dafür, dass alle großen Städte drin sind, bis wir irgendwann alle Ortschaften, die es in Deutschland gibt, drin haben. Wird das so betrieben oder ist das auch eher so, wie es in der Wikipedia tatsächlich funktioniert, dass man sagt, wer Bock hat, der macht halt was. Und deswegen gibt es irgendwie Hawker, ganz kleines obskures Dorf im Südosten, gibt es da schon, aber niemand weiß, was München in QZahl ist.
Also das kann sich schon jede Person selber aussuchen, womit sie arbeitet. Und gerade die Einstiegshürde bei Wikidata ist ja nochmal viel niedriger als bei Wikipedia, finde ich zumindest. Weil ich der kleinste Edit, den ich machen kann, ist wirklich nur eine kurze Aussage. Und bei Wikipedia müsste ich dann, aber würde ich mich jetzt nicht trauen, gleich einen neuen Artikel zu schreiben, habe ich jetzt in vielen Jahren immer noch nicht gemacht, weil ich dann mehrere Absätze an Text schreiben müsste und so. Und bei Wikidata kann ich erst mal ablegen, ist eine Stadt und heißt so und dann reicht das erst mal. Und vielleicht weiß ich noch, dem Bürgermeister ist eine weitere Aussage fertig.
Aber du musst noch mal nachfragen, wenn du sagst, du legst jetzt den Satz ab, heißt das, du schreibst ihn einfach auf und hast dann sozusagen so eine hilfreiche Web, so ein Webinterface, wo man das klicken kann, also sagen quasi oder track and drop oder was auch immer, oder muss man diese Codes kennen?
Also wir haben schon ein relativ hilfreiches Webinterface, würde ich sagen.
Das klingt so, wie das sozialistische Parteikomitee gesagt hat. Also das ist schon sehr, sehr gut und relativ hilfreich.
Also man muss mir auf jeden Fall nicht die ganzen Nummern merken.
Okay, es geht schrecklicher und ich würde sagen im Vergleich zu Wikipedia ist es sogar relativ modern.
Okay, gut, also das reicht schon mal, dass ich sage, ich guck mir das mal an, finde ich gut. Also das ist, sagen die Einstiegshöhe ist geringer. Okay, also man kann jetzt diese Dinge eintragen. Okay, und was macht das?
Das haben die Leute auch schon gemacht. Also die sind ja begeistert. Also das ist...
Mit wem sind die Leute? Kann man das sagen?
Die Nerds, die Community, diejenigen, die einfach geil drauf sind, ihr Wissen mit der Welt zu teilen.
Du und ich sozusagen.
Leute, die echt intrinsisch motiviert sind und den ganzen Tag im Schlafanzug vom Rechner hängen, um das Wissen der Welt zu vervollständigen, damit alle was davon haben. Also wundere ich mich jeden Tag drüber, also ärgere ich mich von Zeit zu Zeit auch drüber, aber eigentlich danke ich diesen Leuten auch jeden Tag, weil hey, neben Linux ist wahrscheinlich Wikipedia das größte Geschenk, was die Nerds uns hier gemacht haben. Und mit Wikidata geht es dann jetzt halt weiter. So, und die sind ähnlich drauf wie Briefmarkensammler, das heißt, es muss dann komplett sein. Das reicht dann nicht, dass ich die norddeutsche Kleinstadt eingetragen habe, ich möchte alle norddeutschen Städte und ich möchte der Erste sein, der die Sammlung komplett hat. Ja, halt nicht eingebaut, das wäre ein bisschen billig, aber das ist glaube ich schon was, was in den Leuten dann im Kopf abspielt. Also neben diesem Altruismus und ich will was Gutes tun, ist dann halt auch sozusagen eine innere Gamification, obwohl wir halt irgendwie da sehr vorsichtig sind, wir wollen da irgendwie keine Spielbude draus machen oder so, aber irgendwas treibt die Leute an und es ist auch wahrscheinlich kein Zufall, dass so der erste Datensatz, der komplett in Wikidata drin war, das war ein Pokémon, weil das ist irgendwie...
Natürlich war das ein Pokémon.
Das ist irgendwie ein überschaubarer Datensatz, den man komplett reinhacken kann und...
Aber warte mal, ich mein, okay, es ist super easy, jetzt sich darüber witzig zu machen, dass da Pokémon drin stehen, aber was macht man denn jetzt damit? Also ich meine, ich hab jetzt irgendwie... Also was ist der Anwendungsfall? Also kann ich mir da ausgeben lassen, wie viele Pokémon sind Feuer und haben eine Angriffskraft zwischen 100 und 110? Also ich kann jetzt nicht weiter fragen, faken, die kriegen, als wenn sie Sinn machen, aber ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, warum Leute das benutzen wollen. Also ihr habt schon, es gibt diese Kodierung von Begriffen, es gibt einen relativ hilfreich, ich möchte die Folge ab jetzt relativ hilfreich nennen, ein relativ hilfreiches Webinterface, mit dem man das machen kann. Es ist auch dafür gesorgt, dass es in verschiedene Sprachen übersetzt wird. Was kann es noch? Also was sind noch sozusagen Milestones, die ihr geschafft habt?
Naja, die Integration in ganz vielen Wikipedia Artikeln. Also wenn du jetzt auf die englische Sprache Wikipedia gehst und dir zum Beispiel den Artikel zum South Pole Telescope anguckst, dann kommt die gesamte Infobox in diesem Artikel aus Wikidata.
Was heißt das?
Also bei den Infoboxen ist es halt total spannend. Wenn sollte Berlin mal wieder einen neuen Bürgermeister haben, garantiere ich dir, in den nächsten Millisekunden ist das in der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia geändert und in der englischen Sprachigen dann auch, weil da gibt es irgendwie viele Leute, die das mitkriegen. Bis das in der Tamilischen, der Sulu, sonst was Wikipedia angekommen ist, kann halt einige Zeit vergehen, wenn man diese Informationen direkt aus Wikidata rauszieht und dann halt eigentlich nur noch das Label übersetzen muss. Dann hat man das halt quasi automatisch und in Echtzeit.
Ja, aber heißt das sozusagen, man kann im Prinzip in der Wikipedia in einer völlig fremden Sprachen-Infobox einbauen, wo man dann im Prinzip ansagt, ok, an dieser Stelle steht der aktuelle Bürgermeister. Das kannst du ja selber nachschlagen, weil das steht ja bei...
Das würde dann automatisch eingefüllt werden, ja.
Heißt das auch, dass es eine vollautomatische Übersetzung geben kann?
Übersetzung würde ich das nicht nennen, aber die Grundfakten sind dann in mehreren Sprachen.
Ok, also im Prinzip so eine Art Steckbrief könnte man automatisch machen lassen. Der Fleece-Text müsste dann...
So ein Artikelplatzhalter quasi. Und das hilft auch schon bei vielen, also was weiß ich, die valisische Wikipedia oder die Esperanto Wikipedia, kleine Wikipedien, wo nicht so viele Leute mitarbeiten. Da gibt es so ein Henne-Ei-Problem. Oder die ganzen Sprachen in Asien oder in Afrika, wo Leute eigentlich ihre gesamte höhere Bildung auf Englisch oder auf Französisch oder sowas verbringen. Und wenn die da was aus dem Internet suchen, dann geben sie was ein und dann kommt die englischsprachige Wikipedia. Und sie kommen gar nicht irgendwie auf die Idee, was zu suchen in der Sprache, die sie zu Hause sprechen. Und das heißt, so eine Sulu-Wikipedia kommt dann einfach nicht vom Fleck, weil die Leute, die gebildet genug sind, daran mitzuarbeiten, die suchen halt automatisch in der englischsprachigen Wikipedia.
Und wenn eh nicht viel drin steht, dann muss man auch nicht dran arbeiten.
Genau, und dann ist es halt auch bei Google nicht prominent, wird nicht gefunden, keiner interessiert sich dafür. Wenn man dann halt so Artikelplatzhalter hat, wo die Daten erstmal in Grundform drinstehen, dann kommt schon mal ein Suchergebnis und dann steht dann dazu, guck mal, das sind die Grunddaten, die wir aus Wikidata haben. Willst du einen Artikel daraus machen? Hier. Und das hilft auf jeden Fall dem, was wir da so sagen, Diversität des Wissens, also es muss halt nicht sein, dass wirklich alles in der Welt nur noch Englisch, ja, oder vielleicht noch Französisch-Deutsch oder so ist, sondern es gibt so viele schöne Sprachen, die halt auch eigene Wissens...
Das will ich jetzt nicht sagen, also den Gedanken, dass es die Einschätzung senkt, ganz spannend, weil ja einfach dadurch, dass, also ich habe gerade gesagt, ich bin ein schlechter Schreiber eigentlich, es hilft immer, irgendwas zu haben, was man dann umformulieren kann.
Ich wollte nur einwerfen, dass das, was Jens gerade beschrieben hat, nicht ein hypothetisches System ist, wie es vielleicht klang. Das ist was, was wir tatsächlich haben und das auch auf kleinen Wikipedias tatsächlich eingesetzt wird.
Und tatsächlich auch auf den Beispielen, die ich genannt habe.
Aber was zur Tierpassierend-Dinge. Aber ist dieser Effekt auch tatsächlich beobachtet? Beobachtbar, Entschuldigung, also dass man sagt, okay, seit es Wikidata gibt und diese Dinge angelegt werden, ist auch tatsächlich erhöhte Aktivität zu bezeichnen?
Also den Artikelplatzhalter, den Jens beschrieben hat, den haben wir, den haben wir aber noch nicht so lange, dass wir da wirklich sagen könnten, das hat einen massiven Effekt. Das müssen wir noch eine Weile beobachten.
Es ist auch verliehten Überlegungen, basierende Hoffnung, die man von dem mal noch nicht sagen kann, ob es tatsächlich so passiert.
Es ist halt brandneu, was wir hier gerade besprechen.
Und vielleicht noch ein wichtiger Punkt, Diversität des Wissens, also Forschung zeigt halt auch, dass die Themen, die in den einzelnen Wikipedien beschrieben werden, selbst in den ganz großen Versionen, überlappen sich zu wesentlich weniger als man denkt. Also allein die deutschsprachigen und die englischsprachigen Wikipedia haben wesentlich weniger Überlappungen, als man sich das üblicherweise so verständigt.
Woran liegt das? Ich würde ja wirklich sagen, es gibt so, also es ist ja immer noch die Idee, die Wikipedia als Lexikon, dann man sagt, also keine Ahnung, da müssen alle Tiere drin sein, alle Hauptstädte der Welt und alles, was in Chemie und Physik so an Basis gesetzt und auch komplizierter Sachen da ist.
Das sind dann so die Sachen, die überlappen. Aber der hier zum Beispiel, der deutschen Schauspieler, der bei uns im Tatort mitspielt, der ist wahrscheinlich in der Deutschsprache in Wikipedia beschrieben, vielleicht noch in der Englischen, aber dann hört es auch schon auf.
Ich bin tatsächlich überrascht davon, weil ich habe, ich war in meiner Naivität davon ausgegangen, es gibt sozusagen so viel, ich sag mal Naturwissenschaft, so ein Wissenschaftskram, der allgemein interessant ist. Oder wo natürlich auch Interesse daran ist, das zu übersetzen, dass eher das den größeren Teil ausgemacht hätte, aber das ist wahrscheinlich der Fall.
Ja, aber was ist denn genau mit dem deutschen Tatort-Schauspieler? Was ist mit dem Lokalpolitiker in Katalonien? Was ist mit der Frauenrechtlerin in Mosambik oder sowas? Die haben alle dann entsprechend in ihren eigenen Landessprachen Wikipedia-Artikel, weil sie da relevant sind, aber nicht global betrachtet.
Ich bin nur überrascht, weil ihr gesagt habt, die Überlappung ist kleiner als der Rest. Das heißt, übertrieben für die Dramatik. Es gibt also mehr Tatort-Schauspieler als physikalische Gesetzmäßigkeiten, die für die Wikipedia interessant sind.
Da spielt dann nochmal der Unterschied rein, was gibt es und wo überschreiben die Leute.
Ist das noch ein Problem, dass man eigentlich immer noch auf der Freiwilligkeit basiert und man sich eigentlich relevantere Inhalte wünscht, aber desinteressierter Leute da einfach nicht hinkommt?
Ja, natürlich. Es ist auch von der Community abhängig. Klar, es gibt in der englischen und deutschsprachigen Wikipedia mehr Artikel zum Herrn der Ringe als zur Politik in Afrika. Was vielleicht auch ein bisschen was mit den Interessen der Community zu tun hat. Was nicht schön ist und was auch verbessert werden sollte, aber...
Man kann es auch nicht vorwerfen eigentlich.
Richtig. Aber es gibt halt wirklich auch Sachen, die für eine Community interessant sind, für eine andere nicht. Und es ist gut, so ein Wissen dann einfach an einen zentralen Speicher zu haben. Und auch das ist Wikidata, einfach ein zentraler Speicher für das Wissen. Also wir haben, ich habe jetzt nicht vor der Sendung nachgeguckt, aber wir haben ungefähr 40 Millionen Wissensgegenstände. Ja, 37 Millionen Wissensgegenstände. Klingt irgendwie, ja, okay. Wenn man das halt in Relation setzt, wir haben in der größten Wikipedia, die es gibt, das ist die englischsprachige Wikipedia, gibt es fünf Millionen Artikel.
Okay, und ein Artikel, kann man so einen Artikel enthält?
Ein Artikel entspricht einem Wissensgegenstand. Also ein Artikel ist über eine Stadt oder einen Menschen und wir haben in Wikidata sieben...
Warte mal, ich weiß nicht, ob du das richtig erklärt hast. Also ein Wissensgegenstand ist etwas anderes als ein Prädikat. Also quasi ist Bürgermeister. Also Bürgermeister sein ist ein Wissensgegenstand oder ist das nochmal was anderes?
Ich glaube, die Person, die ein Bürgermeister ist, das geht ein bisschen alles durcheinander. Aber ja, in den meisten Fällen entspricht ein Wissensgegenstand einem Wikipedia-Artikel. Manchmal braucht man dann zur Vervollständigung der Hierarchie dann nochmal andere Sachen, aber da kommen wir jetzt wirklich in Details rein.
Aber das eine Detail würde ich tatsächlich gerne klären, weil die sagt ja, das Interessante ist, ich stelle Beziehungen, ich stelle Semantik her, indem ich sozusagen das einordne. Jetzt ist ja sozusagen Berlin ein Wikipedia-Artikel, aber Hauptstadt ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ein Wikipedia-Artikel.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es auch ein Wikipedia-Artikel zu Bürgermeister.
Ja genau, das ist die Frage, ob diese 37 Millionen sind, sind das sozusagen nur Dinge, die es in den Artikeln gibt, oder was ist mit diesen Prädikat? Und da gibt es auch Prädikate, die kein Wikipedia-Artikel sind, so umgefragt.
Also es gibt Properties, wie zum Beispiel hat, ist Teil von, oder hat Einwohnerzahl von und so weiter. Dazu gibt es keine Wikipedia-Artikel. Aber diese Items, diese Wissensgegenstände, dazu gibt es meistens Wikipedia-Artikel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es genau verstanden habe, den Unterschied zwischen Wissensgegenständen und anderen Dingen. Also die Einwohnerzahl, sogar die Einwohnerzahl einer Stadt, ist dein eigener Wissensgegenstand, oder ist es eine Eigenschaft, die sozusagen nicht zu diesen 37 Millionen zählt, die du gerade genannt hast?
Die würde natürlich nicht dazu zählen.
Die gehört nicht dazu. So, dann hab ich gesagt 37 Millionen, aber es gibt 5 Millionen Artikel.
In der englischen Sprache Wikipedia, genau. Das heißt also, wir sind eine ganz kleine Obermenge. Also wir haben halt die ganzen kleinen chinesischen Städte drin. Und die katalanischen Kommunalpolitiker und so weiter.
Die jetzt vielleicht auch in der normalen Wikipedia stehen.
Zumindest in der katalanischen Wikipedia, ne?
Okay, gut. Dann erstmal bis hierhin. Gleich, wir machen gleich noch eine kurze Pause, eine kurze musikalische. Und dann wollen wir mal darüber reden, wie man, wir haben jetzt ganz viel darüber geredet, wie man da Dinge reintut. Und jetzt wollen wir gleich darüber reden, wie man da Dinge wieder rausholt. Und vielleicht, vielleicht schaffen wir das auch live. Also wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr mal, also wenn ihr so eine Frage habt, wo ihr denkt, die wollte ich schon immer mal stellen und vielleicht kann die Wikipedia mir beantworten. Also was war so ein Beispiel, was du gesagt hast am Anfang?
Also das klassische motivierende Beispiel waren die 10 größten Städte mit Bürgermeisterinnen. Ich hab grad heute auch mal rausgesucht aus Interesse, die Bundesstaaten bei der Bundestagswahl 2017, wo alle Direktmandate von einer Partei errungen wurden, weil wir die Daten zur Bundestagswahl auch vollständig Wikidata haben, sind sechs von den 16 Bundesländern übrigens. Das könnte man da auch rausholen.
Okay, also falls ihr so eine Frage habt, könnt ihr gerne zum Beispiel twitteren, Chaosradio und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir das noch während der Sendung hier hinkriegen oder erklären, warum das nicht geht und wieder ran scheitern. Jetzt aber erst mal eine kurze musikalische Pause und die ist mit einem weiteren Track vom TipTunes gleiche Wind Compilation Sampler und von Victory Road City of Rumors. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 240, wo es um Wikidata geht. Zusammengefasst könnte man sagen, es ist eine neue Technologie, die es ermöglicht, irre Abfragen über Inhalte zu stellen, die mit Wissen zu tun haben. Vor allen Dingen die Wikipedia, die war zumindest Auslöser des Ganzen, dass man sowas baut. Und wir wollen jetzt mal gucken, nachdem wir uns eine Stunde lang damit beschäftigt haben, wie man da Wissen hineinkriegt, wie man es jetzt wieder hinausbekommt. Und in der Sendungsvorbereitung wurde man eine Notiz überreicht. Und die heißt, ich muss ja mal kurz nachschlagen, wo ist es hier? Spaß mit Sparkle. Das ist S-P-A-R-Q-L. Und ich habe den Verdacht, dass es sich hierbei um ein Nerdspaß handelt und das Ganze eine super komplizierte Abkürzung ist. Wofür steht Sparkle?
Das kann ich jetzt tatsächlich nicht sagen.
Sparkle ist natürlich ein rekoersives Akronym und steht für Sparkle, Protocol and RDF Query Language. Aber was man sich merken muss, ist nur dieses Query Language ist eine Abfragesprache.
Okay, so was wie SQL.
Ja, aber für strukturierte Daten und nicht für, ja, es ist das Relationale Datenbanken. Dass ich mich, Jens Sparkle kann ich noch viel mehr als bei SQL, mich nur darum kümmern, dass ich jetzt tatsächlich beschreibe, wie die Daten aussehen, wie sie funktionieren und nicht wie sie in irgendeiner Datenbank abgelegt sind und wie ich verschiedene Tabellen zusammen joinen muss. Und wie ich die Query jetzt am effizientesten schreibe, sodass sie auch schnell läuft, das kann ich bei Sparkle relativ ignorieren. Ich schreibe, weiß nicht, also für mich ist es relativ intuitiv, die Squieres zu schreiben, aber vielleicht liegt es auch nur an mir, aber ich finde es deutlich einfacher zu bedienen als SQL und auch deutlich mächtiger.
Gleich Gegenmeinung, für mich war es viel schwieriger, meinen Kopf irgendwie in diese Richtung zu prügeln, weil ich halt am Anfang sehr lange in SQL gedacht habe, bis mir klar geworden ist, so kompliziert muss ich gar nicht denken.
Okay, also für Leute, die sagen, weder das eine noch das andere können, das ist ja SQL, ich beschreibe das jetzt mal wirklich sehr, sehr vereinfacht, also nicht mehr aufs Dach springen, nur wenn man selber nicht programmieren kann. SQL ist ja im Prinzip eine Sprache, da geht es darum, in Tabellen zu navigieren. Kann man so ganz grob sagen. Letztlich geht es immer darum zu sagen, hey, guck doch mal, was in dieser einen Tabelle, in der Spalte sowieso, in der Zelle sowieso steht, das kann man auch komplizierter machen und sagen, such mir mal alle Tabellen, Zellen raus aus der Spalte X, die einen Wert größer als, aber es geht immer letztlich um Tabellennavigation. Nachdem ich das jetzt so runtergebrochen habe, um das grobe Konzept zu erklären, könnt ihr mir in derselben Einfachheit erklären, was macht Sparkle?
Also Sparkle kann man sich vorstellen, als operierst du auf einer riesigen Tabelle mit drei Spalten, wo Aussagen drinstehen als Subjekt, Prädikat, Objekt. Zum Beispiel Berlin ist Teil von Deutschland, Berlin hat Einwohner so und so viele Millionen, Person X ist Bürgermeister von Berlin. Und ich muss mich also nicht drum kümmern, wie die Daten über die Tabellen verteilt sind. Sie sind in einer Tabelle und hauptsächlich durch dieses Prädikat, eben diese Property ist Hauptstadt von, ist Teil von und so weiter. Dadurch ist dann festgelegt, was die Daten jetzt bedeuten.
Also man schreibt eigentlich so Sätze, so Hauptsätze mit Subjekt, Prädikat, Objekt. Manchmal lässt man eine Stelle von diesem Satz leer und dann ist da eine Variable drin und sagt, füll das bitte ein. Und so kann ich meine Abfragen halt formulieren.
Okay, also könntest du jetzt quasi sowas machen, nenne mir die Bürgermeister aller Hauptstädte, die größer als 190 Zentimeter sind?
Ja, das wäre kein Problem. Ich hab einen Triple Hauptstadt hat Regierungsoberhaupt, diesen Bürgermeister, diese Person, was dann eine Variable wäre. Du hast nach Hauptstädten gefragt, oder?
Nach Bürgermeister von Hauptstädten, die größer als 190 Zentimeter sind.
Genau, dann muss ich auch noch suchen, dass es ein Land gibt, dass dieselbe Stadt auch als Hauptstadt hat, das nicht eine beliebige Stadt ist. Und dann würde ich noch von dem Bürgermeister die Größe suchen, was auch ein Trippel ist. Bürgermeister hat Größe so und so wie Zentimeter. Und dann kann ich ihn noch einschränken.
Ich beginne zu verstehen, warum das eine Belastung für ein System sein kann. Weil man muss sich immer alles angucken eigentlich, oder? Also es geht vielleicht noch schnell herauszufinden, welche Städte Hauptstädte sind, aber dann muss ich wirklich alle. Und dann nochmal bei allen. Okay, verstehe. Okay, zwei Fragen in völlig gegensätzliche Richtung. Die erste. Was ist das Absurdeste, was ihr mit Wikidata jemals rausgefunden habt?
Dass Hello Kitty fünf Äpfel hoch ist, ist glaube ich ein gutes Kandidat. Ist tatsächlich eingetragen mit Apfel als Einheit. Was natürlich vorgesehen ist, das fällt für, in dem Fall wären es jetzt Zentimeter oder Meter, aber man kann auch Äpfel als Höhe eingeben und irgendwo steht es offenbar drin. Die Schlümpfe sind glaube ich drei Äpfel hoch oder so. Das haben französische Leute, haben das alle sofort erraten können und ich hab davon nie gehört.
Wie kommt man darauf, da sowas nachzufragen?
Ich glaube in dem Fall war ich neugierig, was Leute als Einheiten verwenden und hab geschaut nach allen Einheiten, die nicht tatsächlich physikalische Einheiten sind und dann kam das raus und noch irgendwelche andere Quatschen, die ich mich nicht mehr so erinnern kann.
So richtig absurd ist das alles nicht. Das ist halt überraschend oder manchmal auch einfach interessant.
Okay, überraschend ist es interessant. Nenne einen, wähle einen beliebigen Superleaf. Oder wie froh, wenn ich jetzt als Parkel abfrage?
Was ich gemacht habe, was ich immer gerne erzähle, weil ich so stolz drauf bin, ich hab mir einfach eine Karte geplottet bei Wikidata, bei der Abfragesprache hast du auch die Möglichkeit, dir Daten visualisieren zu lassen. Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, gib mir die Geodaten dann auch als Karte aus, als Open-Street-Map-Karte und dann hab ich gesagt, ich hab eine Vermutung, wo in Deutschland die meisten Ortschaften sind, die auf OW oder ITZ enden. Ich vermute so ungefähr, wo das sein könnte, aber ich möchte das mal geplottet haben. Und tatsächlich kamen dann die Umrisse der ehemaligen DDR raus. Fast alle Städte, die mit OW oder ITZ am Ende sind, liegen im Osten. Es gibt ein paar Ausreißer, aber ja.
Also es gibt so viele Dinge. Aber was ich am interessantesten fand, war die Tatsache, dass offenbar vor einer ganzen Weile mal Baumsamen um den Mond geschickt wurden. Aus diesen Baumsamen wurden dann Bäume gepflanzt, die in Wikidata sind, weil es darüber Wikipedia-Artikel gibt. Und die kann man sich dann natürlich auch auf einer Karte anzeigen lassen.
Also zeige mir alle Bäume aus Mond, Baumsamen auf einer Karte ausgedruckt? Hat eigentlich aus dem Publikum hier vielleicht jemand eine Frage, die er mal stellen wollte oder sich noch nie zu stellen getraut hat? Oder wir hätten jetzt hier Programmierer an der Hand, die das einfach so... Na gut, ihr könnt es ja noch überlegen. Aber andersrum muss man sagen, das ist voll gut, um so Anekdoten zu erzählen, um genau so ein Ding zu machen. Ich kann mir auch tatsächlich vorstellen, mich vor den Rechnen zu setzen und einem abendlang zu überlegen, was für Quatsch ich jetzt rausfinden kann. Die Schuhfarbe von Bürgermeistern oder sowas. Ich bin so auf Bürgermeister geprimed, weil ich die ganze Zeit von Bürgermeistern geredet habe. Aber was ist denn jetzt, um das böse Wort mal zu sagen, die praktische Relevanz des Ganzen?
Die praktische Relevanz des Ganzen liegt zum Beispiel im Datenschonalismus. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an die Panama Paper, wo man dann schnell mal eine Abfrage schreiben kann, die Menschen, die in den Panama Papers genannt werden, was haben die denn so für Berufe? Was sind denn die häufigsten Berufe dieser Menschen? Und da sieht man zum Beispiel, dass das Sportler sind, Juristen und so weiter.
Braucht man dazu Wikidata?
Da hast du dann quasi so eine Infografik, die quasi rausfällt. Also die Daten sind da und du kannst eine Abfrage machen, mit zwei Relationen, wurde erwähnt in den Panama Papers, und welcher Beruf ist das? Und stell mir das als schöne Bubbles dar. So hab ich dann halt datenjournalistisch erstmal eine Aufbereitung. Es hat jemand...
Aber jetzt ohne disputierlich klingen zu wollen, das ist ja was zu sagen, wenn man sich mit so was in den Panama Papers beschäftigt, wie ich sagen will, da klingt das so wie nach, okay, das ist ein effizienter Weg, aber das ist nichts, was ich nicht auch von einem anderen Weg hätte rausfinden können.
Genau, also viele Redaktionen oder so werden sicherlich dann irgendwie ihre anderen Quellen haben, werden Daten zum Teil auch einkaufen oder so, oder haben Leute, die dann halt schöne Infografiken produzieren. Bei uns ist es dann so, dass es halt wirklich jeder auch und jede machen kann. Und das ist halt das Wissen der Menschheit für alle verfügbar.
Aber das ist ja auch ein reteratter Punkt. Wikidata ist nicht nur dazu da, um Dinge rauszufinden, die ich anders gar nicht rausfinden kann, sondern ist auch dazu da, um Wissen breiter zugänglich zu machen.
Richtig, also diese ganzen, was weiß ich, künstlichen Intelligenzen oder Assistenten oder was es gibt, denen kann ich heute Fragen stellen und dann geben sie mir irgendwelche Antworten. Aber das sind halt irgendwie eingemauerte Wissenskönigreiche. Und ich mach mir da persönlich echt große Sorgen. Also es gibt halt einerseits das Web, was wir jetzt durchlesen, aber es gibt halt darunter noch dieses tiefere, dieses Datenweb. Und wenn ich eine Anfrage an Siri oder an Alexa stelle oder so, dann bewege ich mich nicht mehr im offenen freien Web, sondern bewege ich mich im Königreich Google oder im Königreich Apple. Und die haben diese Daten dann auch unter Verschluss. Mit Wikidata habe ich erstmal so eine Möglichkeit, dass ich so eine Daten- und Wissensbasis, wo ich beliebige KI Assistenzprogramme, sonst was, drauf aufsetzen kann, die für alle frei verfügbar sind. Und das ist für mich ganz, ganz essentiell, dass ich ein freies Betriebssystem habe, auch wenn ich es nicht benutze, aber dann, dass es zur Verfügung steht, dass ein freier Browser zur Verfügung steht, dass eine freie Wissensquelle wie Wikipedia zur Verfügung steht und dass auch freie Daten wie in Wikidata jetzt allen zur Verfügung stehen.
Was mir jetzt gerade freut, ist, ihr habt es am Anfang zwar gesagt oder du, Jens, dass du das nicht so bevorzugen würdest, wenn das Wikidata oder so eine semantische Aufarbeitung durch Algorithmen oder Key wiederum erfolgt, aber ich frage mich jetzt gerade, wenn man dieses Ziel erreichen will, was du gerade beschrieben hast mit dem, wir wollen das Wissen der Welt wirklich zugänglich machen, aber gleichzeitig das Problem haben, dass wir darauf angewiesen sind, dass Leute das machen und diese unter Umständen sozusagen sehr spezifisch und fokussierte Interessen haben, ist das auch Teil des Projektes, dass man sozusagen drüber nachdenkt, wie man diese Verbindungen, diese Strukturen sozusagen auch automatisiert vielleicht schneller machen kann? Oder ist das uninteressant?
Das ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Aber dadurch, dass die Daten in Wikidata strukturiert vorliegen, kann man halt zum Beispiel sagen, ok, unsere Daten sehen im Moment so aus. Wir haben Datensätze zu so und so viel Prozent Männern und so und so viel Prozent Frauen. Dieses Verhältnis gefällt uns nicht. Allein zu wissen, dass dieses Verhältnis so ist, ist in Wikidata wesentlich einfacher herauszufinden als zum Beispiel in der Wikipedia. Und das sichtbar zu machen und dann zu Leuten zu gehen, denen das bestimmte Thema am Herzen liegt und die sich dafür einsetzen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Weg, wie wir daran arbeiten.
Was ich meine, das Problem gäbe es ja nicht, wenn man nicht auf Menschen angewiesen wäre, sondern wenn man auch daran arbeitet, dass man sagt, wir wollen Wikidata in Zukunft auch automatisiert befüllen.
Das wird auch gemacht zum großen Teil. Etwa 75% aller Edits in Wikidata sind nicht von Menschen, sondern von Programmen, die Menschen geschrieben haben. Also da arbeiten Roboter und Menschen Hand und Hand. Aber auch diese Programme werden von irgendjemanden geschrieben. Aber wenn jemand, was weiß ich, eine DVD mit statistischen Daten aus China hat, der wird sich dann nicht hinsetzen und die Einzelnen in Wikidata eintippen, sondern der wird ein Pysonscript schreiben, was diese Daten hochlädt, zum Beispiel.
Und der zweite Punkt, der zu beachten ist, ist natürlich, dass die Datensätze, wo man das herbekommen kann, auch nicht aus dem Himmel fallen, sondern die hat auch irgendjemand erstellt, mit seinem persönlichen Bias, mit seinem begrenzten Wissen, mit seinen begrenzten Möglichkeiten. Deshalb selbst, wenn man Wikidata nur mit Maschinen befüllt, hat man trotzdem noch nicht das gesamte Wissen der Menschheit.
Okay, aber zurück zu dem Sparkle-Ding. Was mir noch interessiert, ist, wie zugänglich das ist. Lukas, du hast ja erzählt, du arbeitest jetzt damit oder arbeitest auch daran. Wie bist du dazu gekommen und was ist der Stand da jetzt? Das soll eigentlich, also großes Ziel ja, da kann jeder darauf zugreifen.
Also ich bin dazu gekommen, indem ich Queries, die andere Leute geschrieben haben, angefangen habe zu lesen und dann irgendwann versucht habe, ein bisschen zu bearbeiten. Und hab dann, bin dann praktisch irgendwann dazu gekommen, dass wir selber beizubringen, diese Abfragesprache. Ist aber natürlich nicht so, dass es von jetzt auf sofort geht und dass jeder dafür die Zeit hat, das zu lernen. Wir müssen schon daran arbeiten, das für die Leute zugänglich zu machen, auch wenn sie nicht die Zeit haben, jetzt in Sparkle einzusteigen. Und wir haben eine Seite, wo man fragen kann, ich hätte gerne diese Query, kannst du mir das schreiben? Und dann antwortet meistens jemand, aber es skaliert ja auch nicht. Wir arbeiten schon auch an Systemen, wo sich Leute einfacher ihre Abfragen praktisch schon zusammenklicken können. Also wir haben einen anderen Praktikant, Werkstudent, nämlich sicher, bei Wikimedia, der daran arbeitet, hauptsächlich mit Fokus auf Listen-Generierung, dass da Wikipedia-Autoren auch solche Queries generieren können, ohne jemals das Sparkle, das da letztlich runter liegt, sehen zu müssen. Dass es für die einfacher zu bedienen wird.
Im Moment ist es halt alles noch eine große Nerd-Angelegenheit. Und naja, sind halt alle Nerds, wie wir hier sitzen. Auch du, Marcus?
Ich habe da meine Zweifel manchmal, aber gut.
Ja, aber klar, es ist halt im Moment schon beeindruckend, aber es ist irgendwie wie ein Auto, wo die Karosserie noch fehlt. Und man sieht, der Motor ist schon super. Aber wir haben ja noch ein paar Jahre.
Es fährt aber noch nicht ungefährlich.
Genau, und Kfz-Mechanikerkenntnisse sind notwendig für den Ausdruck.
Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, und das war auch die ursprüngliche Motivation, dass man mit dem Wissen, was man in der Wikipedia ansammelt, nicht nur Menschen lesen kann, sondern auch einen breiteren algorithmisierten und datensucherischen Zugang hat. Aber könnte man denken, das ganze Ding kann man ja vielleicht auch mit anderen Sachen machen. Gibt es da Pläne, oder ist das tatsächlich, weil Wikimedia kümmert sich um die Wikipedia, deswegen ist das Wikidata auch nur für die Wikipeda da? Oder ist da auch schon andere Quellen angezapft worden, oder will man da noch andere Dinge reintun?
Also ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, in welche Richtung deine Frage ging. Daten aus anderen Quellen zu nehmen, oder Wikidata in anderen Stellen auch zu verwenden?
Na beides, momentan klingt es ja so, also die ursprüngliche Idee war, wir haben die Wikimedia, die ist voll erzeugt, das kann nur Menschen lesen und sonst niemand. Wir bauen jetzt so ein Projekt, das Projekt namen wir Wikidata, was letztlich dazu dient, um die Beziehungen, die in der Wikipedia drinstehen, sozusagen so in Struktur zu organisieren, dass wir sie auch maschinenlesbar haben. Und dann kann man sagen, wenn man das hat, dann kann man das ja vielleicht auch auf andere Themenbereiche anwenden. Oder es gibt vielleicht Leute, die sagen so, Entschuldigung, sie haben da diese semantische Technologie, die ist für uns doch sehr interessant.
Genau so was kriegen wir häufig zu hören, und das freut uns. Ich weiß nicht, bist du schon mal mit Eurowings geflogen?
Hm, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, also die haben, die hießen früher Germanwings, bis was passiert ist und so. Und Eurowings hat so eine App, wo man während des Flugs gucken kann, wo bin ich eigentlich? Und dann wird eine Karte angezeigt und Städte drum herum. Dann kann man auf die Stadt draufklicken, kriegt dann so Informationen zur Stadt. Und wir wussten das gar nicht, aber irgendwann hat uns jemand einen Screenshot geschickt, das da im Impressum von dieser App drin steht. Build with the magic of Wikidata. Das heißt, die benutzen das, um ihre Informationen, die sie da haben, anzureichern und zu verbessern. Das ist eine klassische Anwendung. Es gibt andere Anwendungen, wenn man dann zum Beispiel sagt, hier, ich bin in der Stadt und ich möchte irgendwie Denkmäler um mich herum und die Geschichte von diesen Denkmälern sehen, dann krieg ich dann irgendwie gleich, was ist um mich herum angezeigt und bekomme halt Informationen mit Wikidata gefüttert.
Aber das greift dann dabei wieder auf die Wikipeda zurück, oder?
Nee, das greift auf Wikidata direkt zurück und benutzt diese Information, die in Wikidata drin steht, also mit den Geoinformationen und so weiter. Da steht dann, was, hilf mir mal, es gibt so viele tolle Anwendungen.
Es gibt so viele tolle Anwendungen, in der Tat. Es gibt zum Beispiel noch Libreview, das ist eine Seite, die es dir erlaubt, über alle möglichen Dinge Reviews zu schreiben, unter freien Lizenzen. Also du schreibst dann halt deine Buchrezension vielleicht nicht auf Amazon und gibst sie Amazon, sondern auf dem Projekt. Die benutzen Wikidata, um die Gegenstände, die man reviewen kann, zu identifizieren. Oder Quora, die Frage-Antwort-Seite, die benutzen Wikidata auch, um ihren Themenbaum aufzuräumen.
Und dann gibt es noch den großen Bereich der Original Nerds. Also die Leute, die Nerds waren, bevor Computer entstanden sind. Ich rede von Bibliothekarinnen und Bibliothekarinnen. Das sind Leute, die sich jahrzehntelang mit der Ordnung der Dinge beschäftigt haben. Da gibt es Nationalbibliotheken, da gibt es übergeordnete Register, wie sowas gemacht wird. Es gibt ein Verzeichnis, das nennt sich VIAF, das ist für Personenregister, was Bibliothekare benutzen. Und die sagen irgendwie, hey, es gibt so viele widerstreitende Systeme, wie man jetzt eine Person eindeutig mit einer Nummer bezeichnen kann. Aber es gibt ein System, wo ich das dann im Zweifelsfalle auch selber ändern kann und wo eine Webseite hinter steht, die irgendwie fast jeder kennt, nämlich diese Wikipedia und dann gibt es halt dieses Wikidata. Beziehen wir uns doch darauf. Verknüpfen wir unser Ordnungssystem doch einfach mit Wikidata und haben dann, wenn andere Leute sich auch mit Wikidata verknüpfen, den Vorteil, dass wir das untereinander vergleichen können. Das Ordnungssystem der britischen Nationalbibliothek mit dem der deutschen und so weiter.
Warte mal, das heißt im Prinzip, dieses Wikidata ist nicht eine Technologie, die auch in anderen Fachbereichen verwendet wird, sondern jeder, der sich damit beschäftigt, speist das auch in Wikidata ein. Das heißt, alles Wissen landet dort.
Für den meisten Teil schon, ja. Man kann auch eigene Instanzen von der Software unter Wikidata laufen lassen und diese selber speichern. Es gibt Projekte, die das machen, aber ich glaube, die meisten entscheiden sich doch dafür, die Daten in Wikidata abzulegen, wenn das geht, wenn sie relevant für Wikidata sind.
Das ist genau die Frage, die ich mir stelle. Da ist ja die Frage, ich habe jetzt mal einen Fachbereich, sei es Briefmarken, Modelleisenbahnen, Ameisenbeine, Zählen, was auch immer, und habe einen unheimlichen Wissensschatz, den könnte ich ja im Prinzip in Wikidata auch einspeisen. Dann wäre er auch da, tut niemandem weh.
Das wird auch gemacht, ja.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade Relevanz gesagt.
Wir haben Relevanzkriterien, aber die sind relativ großzügig, denke ich. Was ist es? Es muss ein reales Objekt oder Konzept oder sowas sein. Pokémon? Das ist ein Konzept.
Oh, das ist wirklich...
Du musst Quellen dafür haben, das ist noch relativ wichtig. Du darfst es dir nicht aus den Fingern saugen. Aber wenn du eine gute Quelle für etwas hast, dann darfst du es auch eintragen in Wikidata, auch wenn es jetzt nicht an sich relevant genug ist für Wikipedia selber. Zum Beispiel, wenn du ein komplettes Werksverzeichnis von einem Komponisten hast, die individuellen Kompositionen werden jetzt vielleicht nicht relevant, um alle in einzelnen Wikipedia Artikel zu haben. Aber du kannst gerne für jede einzelne Komposition ein Datenobjekt anlegen, wo steht Komponist, Titel, vielleicht gewidmet, wann wurde das komponiert, in welcher Tonart steht das, wie lange ist das, kannst du alles anlegen.
Es gibt Aktivisten, die sich zum Beispiel mit Open Science, also offenen Wissenschaften beschäftigen und die sagen hier, wäre es nicht toll, wenn wir wirklich suchen könnten, wer hat mit wem ein Paper co geschrieben. Und da dann halt jetzt massiv, das bringt uns dann auch Probleme bei der Skalierbarkeit, aber ist erstmal schöner Aktivismus, massiv da wissenschaftliche Papers reinpumpen oder die Titel und die Autoren von wissenschaftlichen Papers, also die Metadaten über diese wissenschaftlichen Papers, sodass man dann halt auch wirklich mal in so einem Zeitstrahl sehen kann, wann gab es denn das erste Paper zum Zika-Virus, wie hat sich das über die Jahre entwickelt, wann gab es die große Explosion der wissenschaftlichen Forschung zu diesem Fachbegriff, und da kannst du dann halt auch Wissenschaft sozusagen anschaulich sehen, also wie sich das über die Zeit entwickelt hat.
Habt ihr schon mal Themen rausgeworfen, oder wie heißt das, Wissensgegenstände, schon mal Wissensgegenstände entfernt?
Wir sowieso nicht als Angestellte, denn wir sind nicht für den Content zuständig.
Genau, wir machen ja nur die Software, wir sind doch nur einfache Arbeiter im Weinberg des freien Wissens.
Natürlich, natürlich. Aber wurden schon mal Wissensgegenstände entfernt?
Also das macht die Community nach ihren eigenen Regeln, es werden natürlich Dupletten entfernt, Schreibfehler korrigiert und so weiter.
Duplikate werden entfernt, oder wenn jemand zur Werbung ein Datenobjekt für dich selber angelegt hat, kann es schon auch sein, dass es gelöscht wird.
Aber das verstehe ich wiederum nicht, wenn es um das Wissen der Welt geht, dann ist ja mal ganz groß gedacht, wollen wir jeden Menschen darin haben?
Ich glaube nicht, nee. Wieso nicht? Also es ist alles super fuzzy und vielleicht in fünf Jahren reden wir da auch ganz anders drüber, den Anspruch, den wir im Moment haben. Ich weiß, dass ganz viel so, guck mal da hinten, dreikömpfiger Affo und ich erkläre das nicht weiter, aber wir haben ungefähr einen enzyklopedischen Anspruch, was auch immer das heißt. Wir sagen irgendwie, das, was ein Laie über ein Wissensgebiet wissen möchte, auf dem letzten Stand der Forschung so, das ist für uns relevant. Für uns sind super spezielle Sachen nicht relevant, für uns ist nicht jeder Einwohner Deutschlands relevant, sondern muss dann auch irgendwie dann schon mal ein Zeitungsartikel zu dieser Person gegeben haben, weil die irgendwas gemacht hat.
Das ist dann gerade auch wieder das Quellenargument. So ein Zeitungsartikel wäre dann eine Quelle.
Naja, aber das, was ich nicht verstehe ist, also Ziel dieses Projektes ist es ja, das Wissen der Welt zu strukturieren. Und wir haben ja auch gesagt, als Beispiel irgendwie Datenjournalismus. Und natürlich kann ich ganz hervorragend Datenjournalismus über die Bevölkerung eines Landes machen. So, wenn ich aber sage, ich will die Bevölkerung gar nicht drin haben, sondern nur relevant, also was auch immer das heißt sozusagen, ich schließe einfach einen Teil aus. Dann verwehre ich mir ja sozusagen genauso. Und ist das dann, ist das eine Ressourcenfrage? Oder warum?
Also die, einerseits ja, wir wollen dahin, dass wir das Wissen der Menschheit abbilden. Das ist Wikipedias Vision, das ist Wikimedias Vision. Aber gleichzeitig müssen wir das abwägen gegen, können wir das, was wir haben, in einem guten Zustand halten mit den Menschen und Werkzeugen, die wir haben. Und im Moment hat Wikidata eine Freiwilligen Community von etwa 17.000 Menschen, die mindestens einen Edit im Monat machen. Mit denen maintainen wir 37 Millionen Items. Kannst du dir kurz ausrechnen, wie viele Items auf eine Person kommen, die nur mindestens einen Edit machen muss. Und da muss man halt dran arbeiten, indem man einerseits mehr Community aufbaut und der Community bessere Werkzeuge gibt, um mit mehr Daten umgehen zu können.
Ja, mehr Datenschatz und weniger Datenmüllhalte.
Ich finde es spannend, dass man immer noch diesen Punkt stößt, weil es diesen Begriff Big Data gibt. Das einzige Spannende, was ich diesem Konzept finde, ist wirklich zu sagen, lass uns doch einfach mal alles mitnehmen und dann gucken wir hinterher, ob wir damit was anfangen können. Ihr habt ja auch über Bias gesprochen, auch die Trennung zwischen Datenmüll und Datenschatz ist ja auch, man weiß es halt nicht. Man muss es halt erstmal festlegen und hinterher, ob es gerechtfertigt ist, wird man nie erfahren, weil man kann es ja nicht nachprüfen.
Na gut. Das sind super große Fragen und irgendwann ist man dann bei der Metaphysik und wo kommen wir eigentlich hin und so weiter. Das ist im Moment der Zustand, den wir uns haben und das ist auch schon abstrakt und nördig genug so. Wer weiß, vielleicht wird es irgendwann ein Big Data Projekt. Ich glaube es aber nicht. Ich glaube, es geht wirklich. Enzyklopädisches Wissen wird ganz lange so der Treiber bleiben.
Wir reden gleich noch mal darüber, wo es hingehen soll. Vorher gibt es noch eine weitere Ausgabe der NerdNews, die von Mo und vorgetragen werden.
Länderchefs verlängern 7-Tage-Regelung. Öffentlich-rechtliche Sender sollen eigene Beiträge länger als bisher im Internet zur Verfügung stellen können. Außerdem sollen ARD, ZDF und Deutschlandradio mehr Freiheit für ihre redaktionellen Angebote im Internet bekommen. Darauf haben sich die Ministerpräsidenten am Freitag bei einem Treffen in Saarbrücken geeinigt. Gleichzeitig wurden die Sender zu verstärkten Sparbemühungen aufgefordert. Ob es eine neue Frist geben soll, ist unklar. Die alte Bundesregierung hat in den letzten Tagen ihrer Amtszeit auf den EU-Rat eingewirkt, dass große Datennetzbetreiber bis zu sieben Jahre lang von Einschränkungen durch EU-Regulierungen ausgenommen werden. Das kommt vor allem der Deutschen Telekom zugute, die zu einem Drittel im Staatsbesitz ist. Zum Ausgleich dafür sollen die Großunternehmen verpflichtet werden, Mitbewerbern die Beteiligung an Projekten zum Netzausbau zu ermöglichen. Ob eine solche Mitarbeit tatsächlich zustande kommt, soll dabei nicht entscheidend sein. Landgericht Hamburg distanziert sich von eigener Rechtsprechung. Das Hamburger Landgericht hält nicht mehr an seinem strengen Haftungsmaßstab bei Verlinkungen auf Urheberrechtsverletzende Inhalte fest. Im September 2016 entschied der Europäische Gerichtshof, dass der Betreiber einer Webseite für das Setzen eines Links auf urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke haften kann, wenn der Link mit der Absicht gesetzt wurde, Gewinn zu erzielen. Vom Linksetzenden wird erwartet, dass er nachprüft, dass das betroffene Werk nicht unbefugt veröffentlicht wurde. Wie dies in der Praxis umgesetzt werden soll, ließ der EUGH offen. Kurz danach bestätigte das Landgericht Hamburg die Linie in einem Beschluss. Wie jetzt bekannt wurde, änderte das Landgericht in einem weiteren Beschluss ein halbes Jahr später seine Auffassung. Eine Nachprüfung sei bei gewerblicher Linksetzung in der Regel nicht zumutbar.
Die Inhalte hier sind auf jeden Fall befugt veröffentlicht, unter anderem auch die Creative Commons Musik vom Chiptunes gleich Win Sampler. Und der Song, den wir jetzt noch hören, ist von Purely Grey und heißt Sunset Bridge. So, und damit haben wir beim Chaos Radio 240 bei Wikidata noch eine halbe Stunde, wo wir uns einerseits mal mit den Plänen zur Zukunft beschäftigen und andererseits hat Lukas während der Songs gerade gesagt, hier, ich habe da noch was, was hast du denn da noch?
Also was ich hatte, war eine Idee.
Ja.
Ich könnte ja mal die, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die richtig heißen, auch die Niederlassung oder so, Lokalveranstaltungen vom CCC in Deutschland suchen, aber hat sich dann rausgestellt, dafür haben wir offenbar noch keine Daten auf Wikidata. Es gibt kein Datenobjekt für den CCC. Hier nicht für den Entropia in Chaosruhe. Das sind die zwei, die ich kenne. Also offenbar haben wir da nicht so große Abdeckung. Aber Lydia hat dann gemeint, man könnte ja zumindest nach Hacker Spaces generell suchen. Und da hat sich rausgestellt, hatten wir, ich glaube, 13 Stück insgesamt, davon drei in den USA, jeweils zwei in Deutschland und im Vereinigten Königreich und noch einen in Österreich.
Da hast du aber noch, also da geht noch was, oder?
Das wäre jetzt die Aufforderung an euch, damit zu helfen.
Ich habe gerade ausverkündigt, ich bin ein Wissensgegenstand. Wie fühlst du dich? Da steht, ich bin ein Mensch. Schon mal gut, ich kenne Leute, die zweifeln das an. Ich sei männlich, Deutsch, Vorname, sei im 20. Jahrhundert geboren und eine Radio-Personality. Immerhin, mein Twitter-Name steht auch drin. Wer macht sowas, oder wird das automatisch angelegt, wenn es irgendwie Wikipedia integriert?
Kannst du nachgucken?
Wie?
Das ist ein Wiki, das heißt, es gibt eine Versionsgeschichte und auch Diskussionsseiten, wenn man sich unterhalten will. Aber in der Versionsgeschichte kann man nachschauen, wer eine Bearbeitung gemacht hat.
Okay, das ist jetzt für die Sendung völlig illere Wand.
Aber wie fühlt man sich so als Wissensgegenstand?
Also gerade, wo ihr jetzt auch gesagt habt Relevanz, und dann nehmt ihr so, aha, ich bin halt so relevant, okay, whatever.
Naja, aber noch mal auf die Hacker-Spaces, Leute, das geht so nicht. Also 13 Hacker-Spaces, das kann doch nicht sein, dass Pokemon komplett in Wikidata drin ist und die Hacker-Spaces nur 13 Stück.
Aber das ist eigentlich auch ein geiles Argument für alles. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass Pokemon komplett drin ist und die Werke von Beethoven nicht. Oder Tageszeitung oder was auch immer. Noch etwas, was wir rausfinden können, wollen? Nein? Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen in Zukunft noch geplant? Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen hin und her verwirrt worden. Das ist alles ganz superschwierig und da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Jetzt denke ich, eigentlich ist das ja auch fertig irgendwie. Es gibt jetzt diese Wissensstrukturen, da kann man auch neu definieren, wenn man die braucht. Aber im Prinzip geht es jetzt darum, das irgendwie aufzuarbeiten, ist eigentlich alles schön. Von hier bis fertig, wo seid ihr gerade?
Also, es gibt noch eine ganze Menge zu tun. Das, was wir jetzt haben, kann schon eine ganze Menge, aber man kann ziemlich coole Sachen damit machen. Aber da geht noch was, zum Beispiel, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, bessere Werkzeuge bauen, um Datenqualität zu sichern und mit mehr Daten umgehen zu können. Das ist ein großes Thema, an dem Lukas zum Beispiel arbeitet. Vielleicht willst du da was dazu erzählen.
Die Menge der Daten, die bearbeitet werden, kann es beschränkt?
Es gibt keine feste Grenze in dem Sinne, aber...
Menschen skalieren nicht so gut. Die meisten brauchen irgendwie bis zu acht Stunden Schlaf pro Nacht, in denen sie nicht in Wikidata editieren können.
Ich dachte, dafür gibt es Mate?
Ja, richtig. Aber wenn dann halt irgendwie Mate Notstand ist...
Okay, verstehe.
Also es ist, wir, es sollen mehr Daten dann halt auch sinnvoll bearbeitet werden können, dass man sieht, okay, da ist irgendwie gerade bei einer Menge von Daten was falsch. Wie kann ich auf einen Schlag was machen? Lukas, erzähl doch einfach mal.
Genau. Also das Datenmodell von Wikidata ist ja sehr flexibel. Es gibt wirklich nur diese Verbindung zwischen Datenobjekten. Es hindert mich niemand daran zu sagen, Berlin liegt in dem Land und jetzt sage ich nicht Deutschland, sondern ich sage Tisch, das Abstrakte Konzept Tisch. Oder ich sage, der Bürgermeister von Berlin ist jetzt der Atlantische Ozean. Also lauter Sachen sind alles einfach Datenobjekte und Wikidata kümmern sich da jetzt erstmal nicht darum, was es für einen Sinn ergibt. Aber natürlich kann man doch schon sagen, auch wenn es Ausnahmen gibt, zum Beispiel Städte, die Katzen zu ihren Bürgermeistern wählen, kann man sagen, meistens sollte jetzt der Bürgermeister ein Mensch sein und jemand, der ein Geburtsdatum hat, sollte auch ein Mensch sein oder generell ein Lebewesen oder ein fiktives Lebewesen. Aber eine Stadt hat zum Beispiel kein Geburtsdatum, sondern ein Gründungsdatum. Und solche Konsistenzprüfungen und Prüfungen, ob die Daten Sinn ergeben, kann man schon definieren und kann man eben, weil die ganzen Daten so maschineliesbar sind, kann man auch superautomatisch durchführen und daran arbeite ich eben.
Aber gerade bei Berlin, vielleicht gibt es ja noch einen Berlin in Katalonien oder wo auch immer. Und wie wird das zu sagen, da hat man aber so zwei Berlins, beide sind ganz was anderes.
Wir haben mehrere Berlins, also es gibt halt Berlin, dieses hier, es gibt dann in Massachusetts, es gibt Berlin, ein Album von Lurit, also die heißen alle Berlin auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch Berlin. Die haben aber alle unterschiedliche Q-Nummern. Deswegen diese Sache.
Das heißt fürs System ist es egal, aber ich muss sagen, diese Regelnachprüfung muss ja schon auf, also der erste Impuls wäre so, Berlin ist kein Album, das ist doch Quatsch.
Die ganze Datelverknüpfung passiert ja nur auf Basis von diesen Q-Nummern.
Ja, ich meine bei den Prüfungsalgorithmen.
Da läuft es genauso, die kommen da eigentlich nicht wirklich durcheinander.
Na es gibt einen Wissensgegenstand, der bezeichnet Berlin die Stadt in Deutschland und einen anderen, der bezeichnet das Musikalbum. Und bei dem einen steht irgendwie ist ein Musikalbum, bei dem anderen steht ist eine Stadt.
Ach so, also das prüfe ich nicht nach, sondern ich sage dann, also wenn es eine Stadt ist, dann hat es aber auch keinen...
Ganz genau.
Also wenn jetzt ein menschlicher Editor verwirrt ist und bei Berlin und das Item Berlin das Album als Hauptstadt irgendwo einträgt, weil er nur das Berlin gesehen hat und nicht nachgeschaut hat, worauf bezieht sich es jetzt, dann können wir aber merken, Moment mal, die Hauptstadt sollte aber eine Stadt sein, das hier ist ein Musikalbum und was wir in Zukunft sogar noch besser machen könnten, was wir aktuell glaube ich nicht vorhaben, wäre aber zum Beispiel dann sogar vorzuschlagen, meinst du nicht dieses andere Datenobjekt, was so ähnlich ist, aber sinnvoller erscheint? Dann kann das der gleiche oder ein anderer menschlicher Editor nochmal anschauen und entscheiden, ja das macht so Sinn, dann ändere ich das jetzt.
Okay. Genau, das ist so ein großes Themenkomplex, an dem wir arbeiten. Ein anderes große Themenkomplex ist strukturierte Daten für Wikimedia Commons. Wikimedia Commons ist das Medienarchiv für Wikimedia. Das heißt, da speichern wir Bilder, Videos, PDF-Dateien und so weiter für Wikipedia und all die anderen Projekte.
Genau, also wenn du ein Wikipedia-Artikel aufrufst und da ist ein Bild drin, kommt das wahrscheinlich von Commons. Genau, das ist unser Medienarchiv.
Und das hat genau dasselbe Problem wie Wikipedia. Die Bilder, Videos und so weiter, da sind nicht ganz Freitext, aber wieder nicht maschinenlesbar beschrieben. Das heißt, ich habe ein Bild von einer Katze, von einem Baum, dann steht da vielleicht als menschenlesbarer Text, Katze vor einem Baum, aber wenn ich jetzt suche, nach Katzen vor Bäumen, wird es schwierig. Und da arbeiten wir dran, genau das wieder maschinenlesbar zu machen und damit all die Bilder, all die Schätze, die in Wikimedia Commons vergraben sind im Moment, weil man sie halt nicht findet, zu heben.
Und wenn das Bild heißt Katze vor einem Baum, und das ist auf Deutsch der Titel, dann habe ich ja nochmal Glück gehabt, wenn es irgendwie Kat in front of tree ist, dann wahrscheinlich auch noch das, während das zweite was mir einfällt. Ey, was ist, wenn das auf Chinesisch ist? Ich wüsste ja noch nicht mal, wie ich das eintippen soll. Und wenn du dann einfach sagen willst, ich suche aber ganz dringend Bilder von einer Katze vom Baum, Grundfarbe grün, unter der CC-Lizenz CC by SA Version 4, aus den Jahren 89 bis 2003. Wenn ich das irgendwie in die Suche eingeben kann, das geht nur, wenn die Metadaten von den Bildern strukturiert abgelegt worden sind in einer strukturierten Datenbank. Dann haben wir einfach die Technologie von Wikidata genommen und das dann auf dieses Medienarchiv zu machen. Das heißt, ich kann wirklich nicht nur über die Wissensgegenstände in der Welt, sondern ich kann dann auch über die Medien, die es dann gibt, in diesem Medienarchiv strukturierte Abfragen machen und sagen, wie viele Bilder gibt es eigentlich in Commons, wo Katzen drauf sind.
Aber das ist sozusagen eine eigene Instanz, eine eigene Wikidata Instanz? Das hat nichts mit der Weltwissensliste zu tun.
Genau, das ist eine eigene Instanz. Dieses Commons bekommt einfach die Technologie von Wikidata spendiert und läuft dann anders. Genau, und dann haben wir halt zwei große Sachen. Einmal Wissensgegenstände, Bilder und Töne und so weiter, die man semantisch auszeichnen und durchsuchen kann. Dann fehlt eigentlich nur noch das, was den Menschen eigentlich zum Menschen macht, also wo das Denken eigentlich anfängt. Die Sprache. Wenn man die jetzt auch noch mal semantisch aufbereiten und durchsuchen könnte, wie geil wäre das denn?
Jetzt kriege ich gerade einen Knoten im Gehirn, wie kann sowas aussehen?
Wie ein Wetterbuch. Also im Duden hast du zum Beispiel Tisch, ist ein Substantiv und wird so und so gebeugt, all das. Und wenn du das in strukturierter Form vorliegen hast, dann noch mit Übersetzungen in andere Sprachen, dann kannst du das für ganz viele Dinge benutzen. Zum Beispiel automatische Textgenerierung, automatische Übersetzung, Sprachforschung, all diese Dinge.
Ich habe dann ein Wörterbuch, was Menschen und Maschinen lesbar ist. Übersprachlich angelegt, weil ich die Technologie von Wikidata benutze, halte ich fest, also ich sehe, du sitzt bequem deswegen. Also es wird jetzt mal abgefangen in 300 Sprachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwo auf der Welt ein Wörterbuch gibt, maltesisch-estnisch. Ich glaube, der Markt ist sehr klein. Das könnten wir mit strukturierten Daten für Wiktionary, mit Wikidata für Wiktionary, könnten wir sowas schaffen. Also wir könnten beliebige Sprachkombinationen als Wörterbuch, maschinen- und menschenlesbar, quasi erstellen. Das heißt, du hast einen Text, du kannst dann gleich sehen, okay, dieses Wort, diese grammatische Funktion, willst du zu diesem Wort auch noch die Bedeutung haben? Und hier ist der Wikipedia Artikel und das wissen wir doch über uns. So groß ist der Bürgermeister in dieser Stadt und so weiter. Das alles in maschinenlesbar, verknüpftbar, unendlich remixbar. Ja, abgefahren ist das denn.
Klingt gut, aber ich muss ja fragen, funktioniert das perfekt oder ist das dann sozusagen nur, also weil zu übersetzen ist ja immer so eine Sache. Also es gibt eine wörtliche Übersetzung, dann gibt es sagen der Kontext einer Besetzung. Kann das dabei auch helfen oder?
Auf jeden Fall, denn genau diese Verwendung von Wörtern in unterschiedlichem Kontext, in unterschiedlichen Bedeutungen, ist das jetzt eher ein formal genutztes Wort oder eins, das ich in der Bar mit einem Kumpel benutze und so. Das sind genau die Dinge, die wir dann auch festhalten wollen und die so wichtig sind für automatische Übersetzungen zum Beispiel. Denn wenn ich nicht weiß, ob Worte Kolokialism ist oder nicht, kann bei der Übersetzung ganz schön viel schiefgehen.
Man lästet auch gerne über automatische Übersetzungen, da sieht man auch noch einiges zu machen, aber Google Translate funktioniert schon erschreckend gut zum Teil. Er hat den Nachteil, es ist Google Translate, das heißt arbeitet auf einer Basis, die mir erstmal nicht zugänglich wäre. Mit Wikidata für Wiktionary hätte ich dann halt auf einen Schlag, Bäm, millionenfach eine freie zugängliche linguistische Datenbasis, wo ich dann automatische Übersetzungsprogramme drauf aufsetzen könnte, wo halt nicht irgendwie Google den Daumen drauf hält, sondern wir alle.
Wird daran gearbeitet, ist das momentan so eine fixe Idee? Also die geil klingt, aber wo man noch nicht dran sitzt?
Da sitzen wir aktiv dran an der Entwicklung der Infrastruktur dafür.
Wer ist jetzt, seit ihr drei Leute das, wie ihr hier auf dem Sofa sitzt, und dann noch der eine Werkstudent irgendwie oder vor allen Dingen ist das nur Deutschland oder hat Wikimedia in verschiedenen Nationen Teams, die auch an Wikidata arbeiten, oder wie läuft das?
Also die Softwareentwicklung an Wikidata läuft tatsächlich hauptsächlich bei Wikimedia Deutschland ab. Für die strukturierten Daten auf Commons ist jetzt tatsächlich die Wikimedia Foundation in den USA zuständig und die machen dafür die Softwareentwicklung. Und wir unterstützen sie, glaube ich, dabei. Und aktuell sind wir eher dabei an diesen strukturierten Daten für Wiktionary, an dem Wörterbuch Daten eben. Das ist das, worauf wir uns gerade konzentrieren. Wir sind dabei die Softwareentwicklung von Wikimedia Deutschland mit, wie viele Leute?
Dutzend. Die, die an Wikidata arbeiten, so um die zehn.
Zehn Leute, die programmieren und so. Die ganze Softwareentwicklung ist ein bisschen größer. 25.
Und was ist denn so dein ganz konkretes nächstes Feature? Also klar, wir hätten gerne so Wiktionary, Wikidata und so, aber was passiert morgen oder übermorgen?
Übermorgen gibt es eine Konferenz. Wir haben uns gedacht, nach fünf Jahren Wikidata kann man ja auch mal eine internationale Konferenz zum Thema machen und wir laden alle...
Und kann man feiern?
Genau, kann man feiern, den Geburtstag. Wir laden halt Leute aus der ganzen Welt ein. Wir haben gedacht, das ist so ein nördiges Thema, mehr als 200 Leute kommen bestimmt nicht, zack, war alles ausverkauft. Im Moment ist es nicht möglich, da jetzt noch ein Ticket zu kriegen. Aber die Leute, die das Video-Streaming beim CCC machen und so weiter...
Und du meinst jetzt gerade hier das machen?
Zum Beispiel, genau die. Die werden uns aber bei der Konferenz helfen. Das heißt, man kann zumindest die Vorträge dann noch mal live im Netz sehen. Vor Ort im Tagesspiegel, ist leider ausverkauft und da ist irgendwie die Grenze so. Aber man wird das alles im Netz sehen können. Und da gibt es halt Leute, die sich beschäftigen mit... Ich arbeite in einem Museum und möchte diese ganzen Kunstgegenstände, die ich da habe, in Wikidata reinbringen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, wie kann ich Wikidata in der Erziehung einsetzen? Wie kann Wikidata für Politik eingesetzt werden? Also politische Daten, da irgendwie Journalismus drüber machen. Es gibt Leute, die beschäftigen sich dann nur mit Ontologien, also mit der philosophischen Lehre von der Ordnung der Dinge. Es gibt ganz viele technische Sachen, wie kann ich das und das programmieren. Es gibt die ganze Zeit irgendwie einen Ort, wo man Abfragen dann selber erstellen kann. Und am Sonntag feiern wir dann halt den fünften Geburtstag. Und dann gibt es Geschenke für Wikidata. Das ganze Jahr haben Leute neue Features programmiert und die werden dann ausgepackt und gezeigt.
Wir haben ja zwei, die schon öffentlich sind. Na gut, das eine ist jetzt sehr technisch. Das andere ist eine deutlich verbesserte Suchfunktion. Die alte Suchfunktion auf Wikidata hat hauptsächlich auf dem Artikel Text operiert, der halt in unserem Fall nicht Text ist, sondern etwas, was der Mensch nie zu Gesicht bekommt. Der bekommt die strukturierten Daten zu Gesicht. Und jetzt haben wir eben eine neue Suchfunktion, mit der ich mich nicht wirklich auskenne, aber sie funktioniert auf jeden Fall deutlich besser. Die Ergebnisse sind relativ viel weiter. Wenn ich nach Berlin suche, kriege ich dann zum Beispiel als erstes die Hauptstadt und nicht das Album oder die Stadt in Minnesota oder wo auch immer das war.
Okay, ich habe gerade ein totales Déjà-vu. Ich glaube, irgendwie die Verbesserung der Suchfunktion scheint bei vielen Projekten ein gutes Ding zu sein.
Na ja, immer die Suche muss besser werden, die Eingabe muss benutzerfreundlicher werden. Irgendwann sind wir auch da.
Hilft alles nicht. Zum Abschluss, weil ja nicht nur die hier sitzt seit Nerds, sondern auch viele von den Menschen, die vor dem neuartigen Grundfunk-Opfangskrieg sitzen, sondern das vielleicht jetzt gerade hören, sind Nerds oder möchten gerne welche werden. Welche Art von Hilfe kann man euch denn zugutekommen lassen, wenn man das Projekt Total Teufel in die Winde, da möchte ich auch was tun, außer Hacker-Spaces eintragen. Das hatten wir ja schon gesagt.
Genau, also weniger Hilfe brauchen wir bei Pokémon. Der Datensatz ist vollständig. Weiß nicht, ob ich das bereits erwähnte. Nein, also sucht euch irgendwie ein Thema aus. Das können Barockkirchen in Oberbayern sein, die ihr dann vervollständigt einfach. Das wäre so eine Sache. Also die meisten fangen auch einfach damit an, dass wir einfach mal gucken, wir haben eine tolle Funktion around me. Und dann sieht man einfach Wissensgegenstände um die jetzige Position.
Auch Pokémon?
Also was weiß ich, irgendwelche Bauern decken umher herum. Und da fehlen dann vielleicht auch noch mal Daten, die man nachtragen kann. Manchmal fehlt ein Foto, das man noch eintragen kann.
Aber ist es die Hilfe, die ihr braucht, nur die Vervollständigung des Datensatzes? Oder kann man auch sagen, ich gucke mal euren Quellcode an, mache Qualitätsmanagement oder programmiere ein neues Feature?
Auf jeden Fall. Also wer mit coden will, gerne. Sowohl an der Software selbst, aber auch Tools bauen, die unsere Daten benutzen. In andere Tools integrieren. Wir hatten vor kurzem zum Beispiel ein Programm, wie hieß es, Bear Tunes?
Genau, das ist ein Apple Programm, wo man halt irgendwie seine Musiksammlung durchsuchen kann und dann halt irgendwie so Playlisten zusammenstellen kann mit nach der und der Stimmung und so. Und eine der Quellen, wo diese Playlist-Übersichtsintelligenz-Maschine damit gefüttert war, war dann halt Wikidata. Das ist ein kommerzielles Programm, aber das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Also ihr müsst nicht unbedingt freie Software schaffen. Ihr könnt Wikidata immer benutzen. Das ist vielleicht noch was, was man noch extra erwähnen soll. Also Wikipedia ist unter einer freien Lizenz Weitergabe unter gleichen Bedingungen oder so verfügbar. Weil Wikidata ist es eigentlich die radikalsmögliche Option. Das heißt CC0, Public Domain, keine Angabe der Quelle ist notwendig. Das ist manchmal einfach pragmatischer. Du kannst nicht in deiner App sagen, diese Temperatur wurde ihnen präsentiert von. Also für jedes kleine einzelne Datum kannst du nicht eine Quelle angeben. Außerdem ist es so, dass einzelne Fakten eigentlich nicht unter das Urheberrecht fallen. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe durch die Schöpfung meines Genius herausgefunden, dass Goethe die und die Körpergrößerte oder so. Das ist dann einfach Allgemeinwissen und es fällt nicht unter das Urheberrecht. Und das dritte ist, dass wir sagen, wir machen CC0, wir machen Public Domain, das ist auch eine wichtige Art, dass es dann einfach alle nachnutzen können, kommerziell und nicht kommerziell.
Das ist korrekt. Wir freuen uns natürlich über jeden, der Wikidata benutzt. Wir freuen uns aber noch mehr über jeden, der Wikidata benutzt und es sagt, dass er Wikidata benutzt. Und noch mehr über jeden, der es sagt und Freisoftware produziert.
Okay, ich habe jetzt noch eine allerletzte Frage an euch. Das heißt also, man kann diesen Daten dazu nutzen, man kann damit machen, was man will, und man kann sie auch als Grundlage für neue intelligente Technologien benutzen. Gibt es irgendeine Art und Weise, dass ihr sichergestellt habt, dass nicht die Skynet Technologie den Terminator bringen wird, auf Grund von Wikidata entsteht? Oder müssen wir damit einfach rechnen?
Also, ich mache mir da nicht so viele Sorgen. Ich denke, wenn der Moment kommt, dass Wikidata ein eigenes Bewusstsein entwickelt und sich zur Skynet weiterentwickelt, wird es sich schon daran erinnern, wer dann von Anfang an dabei war und die ersten Zahlen mit programmiert hat. Und dann, denke ich mal, begrüße ich dann auch unsere Maschinenherrscher entsprechend und rechne mir da gute Karrierechancen in der neuen Weltordnung.
Wikidata, ein tolles Projekt, damit möchte ich in Erinnerung bleiben. Und bedanke mich recht herzlich bei Jens, Lydia und Lukas für einen Einblick in dieses Projekt, das das Weltwissen möglicherweise auf eine Art und Weise darstellt, dass auch Maschinen etwas damit anfangen können. Die Links dazu wird es in den Shownotes zur Sendung geben. Danke, dass ihr hier wart.
Danke, dass wir hier sein durften.
Danke, sehr gerne. Vielen Dank, liebes Publikum, dass ihr aufmerksam und gespannt zugehört habt. Und das war das Chaosradio 240. Es wird höchstwahrscheinlich eine relativ hilfreiche Information, die ich also gleich gebe, das nächste Chaosradio auch in Berlin stattfinden. Wir arbeiten gerade dran, dass wir auch die Sendung bei Fritz hier aus der Berlin, Hauptstadt, Deutschland machen können. Genau Informationen am besten über den Twitter-Account verfolgen. Da wird es dann genaueres geben. Jetzt erstmal noch eine letzte Nachricht von mir, Marcus Richter, instance of human, wie ich heute gelernt habe. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
And how many 40s they smoke.